pulled up to calabasas ready for where i
might turn to a savage i just showed up
with the crewy the baddest you just
showed up like you might need some
practice uh you going down for the count
it's going down tonight i do it all for
my family you do it all for the likes i
hit that bell and i'm ready to fight
turn me up turn me up turn me up they
want the belt they don't work and know
don't mess around enough hurting them i
say the wrong thing make it personal
[Music]
[Applause]
were you sitting down i was sitting down
and i stood up and i said what you look
a lot like he's seven foot tall you're
athletic thank you very much and i am
dude and i am dude what did you just say
well i do crazy box jumps he knows he
can tell he's really i can see the
explosion yeah it happens don't call him
i do explode by the way he sat in the
chair i could tell that dude does box
jumps for real 100 to me right now you
line up 99 sports i beat him at 98. oh
that's a good damn thing i don't know
red shirt i don't think i heard i heard
that he would whip your ass in
pickleball right yeah you already
whooped your ass in pickleball nobody
nobody beats me at this table of
pickleball we know that yeah well i got
a one bigger what's pickleball yeah yeah
i'm
now that sounds like a sport i really
can't get behind
don't do that dude yeah dude
i gotta text we didn't know each other
that well yeah i said i said bye we hung
out all night and i said bye and i just
get a text i said did you feel that and
i go i go
what and i just get
us
that's powerful yeah
i thought i was texting someone else you
know what if um
why do you have inside out shirt he is
right why do you have yeah right you
know weird guys so the cool thing about
this is it you can it's reversible like
this that makes sense which is why i
bought it this feels great against my
skin and you can wear it the other way
that's why i get peels speaking of
younger you feel like an old guy your
face looks tight and you look adorable
he he's 43. yeah he's got absolutely so
young community guys yeah all right
you're young you're what
mm-hmm third all right he's thirty-eight
thirty-nine in march where do you guys
push in here march what march eighteenth
that's my son's birthday jonah he's
[ __ ] he's definitely i knew we were
family
i was missing
there sorry it's okay it's okay i'm
older i am older this
you live in the shadows okay and it's
his white skin man yeah it's it's you're
you have you almost match your coat you
know what it is it's not even white it's
not even white skin it's a weird color i
don't know what the color is
it's like pale i don't know
he has a salad other than says sour
they say sour
yes uh a hundred percent have heard that
before so it still sucks and yes i have
and there's nothing so it sucks and
there's nothing you knew about i wanna i
wanna be like no but like
no i'm a i'm a new color and it's it's
almost it's dead it's off dead is what
i'm gonna call it
well you know what oh
you know what
what are you offline
we're next to you're good looking kid
but you're next to these guys are cute
couple cutie pies big athletes that's
fine dude i got more like when i look
okay here's the deal when i i i'm a
total drink of what i'm
193 right and i go uh you know
shredville my back's it's nice it looks
like a sometimes the tur you know what i
mean like captain america's shield
puppet that's not true but the truth is
i'm the big guy in the room you guys
come in i'm not but i could be heroin
chic in a way do you know what i mean
like i can be i can be very and that's
when i get the musical girls right so i
get all excited you guys are in the room
i move you know you're different you
know what you different you stay shy too
you hide behind your head i do you hide
behind your head and i say this a lot
who me
i do that and it's like oh interesting
right but when you guys are gone i'm the
guy you're gonna understand
different when different people are
around dude
you alpha up right now you better down
but you alpha but baiting down is really
outfitting up when you know who you are
and you're moving it's a cerebral move
that's it cerebral that's exactly it's
like it's like hey let them think
they're filling the room but i'm really
taking the juice here yeah
i had matt on uh food truck and
flashback fight nights last night yeah
that like he graciously put the one that
he want my ass in which is really nice
hey let me choke you unconscious while
you watch hey check this out man yeah
but so weird
yeah but i hear you it was how awkward
was that that was weird it was really
weird it's not the worst you i've done a
lot of shows
a ton yeah a ton with a million fighters
yeah none better than that mitchell uh
that's nice wait wait wait
this food truck one the ones coming out
best shows i've ever yeah
even the team was like holy [ __ ] really
dude really
how long ago i go you should be behind
you you're charismatic you're funny you
should be working behind the camera well
what do i tell you brandon's becoming my
ep like we got oh now now you listen to
him after i told you [ __ ] listen we
know he's not gonna get it yeah i mean
we'll give you the ideas but your boy
has carried through yeah your boy how do
you say you got here you know what he
does you know what he does no you're
you're mom a bird you fed me right he
fed me and then two weeks later no don't
say two weeks later
no no don't do that because you you
might
careful don't do that with the wings
because he gets i know i'm good that's
weird
have you seen them no it's not something
about it all right i'm in the center you
guys you
know in the center
i'm not right or left dude but don't let
me see if this pushes you to the right
i don't want to do this i don't want it
to pop up early right now i know please
you know you know rogan's not working
tonight what what what are you doing
they said it was a conflict issue i'm
not buying it wait a minute you're
saying that because
hold on chris you probably just got
something else there's like maybe you
got sick or something chris there's an
explanation
chris what happened it's fine look at me
i know there's a probably a very logical
explanation but he was probably has held
a lot of tickets and it was stay in the
center he
is spreading rumors hey chris but
because they sweat they switch you don't
think spotify had anything to do with it
do you no chris
chris the guy's a businessman yeah wait
wait what happened all right chris who
who owns espn who owns espn
disney
hit it
push me
come back to us please
chris
what happened nothing to do guys i hate
yet to bring him out man i'm not talking
about you i'm sorry i'm sorry i did that
i needed to see that matt
matt chris is a centrist politically
yeah but sometimes with the insanity
they're pushing him they push him he's
got to wear his mask behind his ears and
what happens is they they start pushing
them over you guys are getting that
becomes far right chris and we want to
keep that we want to keep i'm in the
center
hold on right now i'll tell you what you
can't handle man listen i'm excited
that's what can you handle it's called a
transition listen i'm excited to
announce that my manscaped has launched
their ultra premium collection wow
believe it or not it's for your not so
private parts that's right yeah
wait a minute
now they have something for your other
oh dude i'm talking about leveling up
level up your hygiene routine with your
favorite manly set this is an all-in-one
skin and hair care kit for everyday man
and covers you from head to toe
literally manscape is trusted below the
waist now trust them with the rest of
the four million probes 20 off you can
dude join the four million bros
worldwide
trust manscape by going to manscape.com
for 20 20 off and free shipping with
code cfc all right get it done man they
got premium deodorant not for your balls
your time out for your armpits they got
hydrating body spray materials body wash
two-in-one shampoo and conditioner plus
a free gift a three pack set of lip balm
that's made up of ingredients such as
vitamin e peppermint and most you guys
care about the soil you know you guys
don't care they do all of it i bet you
smell so dude i love the two in one
shampoo i lather up my hair two on one
come on daddy two and one yeah two birds
one stone can't beat it baby you it
doesn't work for me but yeah it's not
for your hair but we'll get it going man
all right uh get 20 off and free
shipping with code cfc at manscape.com
that's 20 off and free shipping with the
code cfc
manscape.com wow
okay wes i'm sorry man i'm glad you got
to see far right chris though it was it
was a little intense
you know you know what's amazing is that
the the mane got more full the more
right he got his feathers i don't know
it's just feathers popping i have a
question for matt
can i get a beverage of something i
can't matter hold on hold on
some west tigers i mean i'm going to try
and get some thick tie i got a question
brian has a question for matt and i'm
sure it's really good it's a good
question and not boring oh it's not
emotional
matt matt we're looking at a super bowl
it's coming up
fair enough i'm listening to you i'm
gonna play you played in the nfl for how
many years uh four seasons four seasons
yes sir giants yeah minnesota giants
giants 49ers vikings defensive
so i was active with the giants and the
vikings oh weird wikipedia is off okay
anyways carry on so you were you were a
defensive tackle yes well uh with the
giants as a defensive tackle i was a
pass rusher okay and then with the 49ers
and the vikings i became a swing man so
i played all four across the line and i
passed rush from all four positions had
some speed oh yeah
absolutely athletic plus right yeah
now you are you are a trim 285 right now
yeah 285 that's 285 285 do you have a
scale here i'll jump on it no
no no no scales i don't do this
i'm afraid he's afraid he's tripping
yeah
uh stop that carnivore thing nope yeah
no i mean
because
you're gonna die early you're gonna die
earlier i mean look it looks like i was
when you were walking around here today
i was like dude that dude's that's just
like some some massive quads i know it's
crazy yeah kind of workouts
yeah i do jumps i do um
i do you know i do squats but whatever
going right to be honest you were
getting bulky yeah i was getting bulky
and then what happened was i was like
you know it was hurting i was hurting
all the time i was hurting all the time
my joints joints were hurting all the
time not my knees my uh my uh what do
you call them the [ __ ] in your yeah
groin you're so excited yes muscles and
uh yes no and uh yes taught you well and
um
that was hurting a lot and my lower back
and then i stopped for a bit and it got
all better and now i feel [ __ ]
amazing oh there we go okay but but
walking up the stairs my heart beats a
little bit too much and i feel like i'm
gonna die so i gotta get back into it do
you uh do any of you guys
ever do cold plunges yeah no no no no no
brian will lie
with me i do my five-year-old does it
because tom brady hey guys hey he loves
tom brady yeah so did you know
apparently tim
itty bitty a comedian tiny heart
kevin hart dies
tim but that's okay kevin tim hardy yeah
yeah
there we go
he does a show very successful yeah and
he has culture oh right he does yeah
you're very successful i think if we did
the biggest show if that wasn't a thing
i'd say that should be a thing that's
great great idea i can't wait to start
watching it can i just find out about it
oh it's amazing we've got to rewind
we've got to rewind and he knows why we
have to rewind because when you said do
you guys do cold plunges he said yes
brian said yes immediately you know how
long i've been his friend where i know
it's a lie so
i go that never happened
what's up chris what's up
but this counts because i what i meant
was no i would do one okay
yeah so next time i'm out here yeah i'll
i'll get a tub yeah and i'll get ice and
we'll put you in there and we'll do
we'll do a four-minute tub plunge
there's no problem you know why and
michael beyond do you know why i do it
and i'm not afraid of it because i know
well no you don't do it i do do it well
you don't do it i've done it but
you would do it
in the doing area you're not doing a
contest one time where you put your hand
in ice water okay everybody pulls it out
because it starts to hurt oh that's what
i knew was that your hand goes numb
after a little while and there's no pain
it's coming same thing with your body
okay so a lot of people go it's too cold
and i go i'll just wait until the pain
it's when you're nuts right but you
haven't done it yet or like you go like
if you plunge to your neckline i meant
that's what you want yeah and that's
that's uh i think wait why were you
asking them man just because i i i've
just recently been saying the show i've
recently no no no actually they're
injured
i digressed but um there were uh i've
been reading a lot of studies lately
about yeah the overall you know what i'm
sick of people going
those machines like grogan swears by him
oh that's [ __ ] cool have you ever
done cryo i'm like bro yeah i told wrong
i'm like dude i'm sure they're great for
you i'm telling you nothing is better
than actual ice and water yeah it's way
simpler for your paid membership i'm
going to do that
i said that one time because they were
all talking about cryo and that's a new
thing brendan i went back like this he
goes yeah and i went what he goes uh
well i mean i don't know anything about
sports because i've never done it was
all comics talking about it
i just know that i just know that uh
i've done cryo and i've also done ice
baths and when you're a real athlete and
you're you know you're in pain and you
want to bring inflammation down that's
what you do which is um i mean lebron
tom brady does kobe bryant whatever i
mean you know
who are they so you were saying about
ice baths what do you like about cold
plunges um i i like how
i genuinely feel like i
have more energy and i feel i think
clearer me too throughout the day uh
because purdue i live at purdue uh we go
in there and the training they have
giant giant hot tubs and cold ups yeah
massive like you know what the cold tubs
i hate is it the steel ones but and it
because i i need to do cold i need to do
cold plunges to get my dick down to nine
inches oh yeah yeah otherwise it's slow
heavy and shape
yeah i'll put your face in it yeah i
should i should put my face in it yeah i
think you and i should both increase
this line
diet yeah i'm gonna i'm on a seafood
diet oh yeah i see food and i eat it
you know what i was i was talking we're
at the beach today right so we're at uh
venice beach yep uh we're bouncing
around stepping on a needle uh oh no
thank god yeah thank god uh but i did
step on some shrooms and i have to eat
them at the same time
out there in venice beach just a little
bit did you play paddle ball really good
or something uh it got weird but it was
lovely uh a good go but um
we are out
bouncing around today and um
you asked me about
uh
oh
hey hey chris no hold on before you do
that your mouth chris have you ever how
old you're 41 in 41 years have you ever
you know they're friends they haven't
seen each other forever what do you eat
today uh ever in your life because i'm
looking at it i'm i'm at the moment
it's a brilliant thing yeah but i want
to know what a pro athlete so
i was talking about i was talking about
why today some dude walked by today some
dude walked by today and had a
phenomenal physique and i was like babe
it's venice beach like you're i'm never
gonna look like that and she goes i know
and it's like i won't give up eating
what i want and drinking
for the for the aesthetics because i'm
not i'm not superficial and i'm not vain
enough too much like i'm vain enough to
care but i'm not vain enough to give up
your ego doesn't need that though
because you've accomplished crazy [ __ ]
yeah but i still want to pay attorney
and have a chest and be [ __ ] chiseled
up and be like what's up i'm a sexy
[ __ ] but i also like want my
wife to be like hey let's go [ __ ]
rage today and let's get [ __ ] weird
and i'm like yes let's go do that and
you can't rage and get weird and be
shredded no because i mean much work
okay if i could if i could rage if i
could rage and be in shape i'd be in
shape now sure it's too much you don't
want to be but you don't want to be like
shredded i mean maybe you do but that's
for you nobody gives a [ __ ] about that
you know what i know that my wife like
she like she wants to touch something
fancy but she wants to be like come here
you fat mother yeah yeah yeah it's hard
because you feel comfortable yeah
yeah yeah it's exhausting it's hard
being you i mean it's like well being 55
and being this [ __ ] you're 55 yeah
there's 55 look at his hair dude you
knew that good god you were one second i
saw your teacher i i see your hair i saw
it on the way here on the ground
not on the trail not cool we could find
you we could find you if you go and if
you go and hide we could find yes but
you know what i mean what's that dude's
name
oh
that's straight right that's right
that's who that is oh [ __ ] i thought
that was where is he from from dagestan
i'm betting against he's not i'm betting
on him i thought that was uh
calvin castle they look a lot like that
kelvin
crypto he looks like a miniature kelvin
yes we gotta go um oh by the way uh
i i uh doesn't um
doesn't the rock sponsor shoes now the
the the slippers slippers you know why
though right daddy no well who owns the
ufc wme who matches who who's the rock's
agent
how do you know all this [ __ ]
you know dude i've been around but why
do you know all this [ __ ] it's my
business yeah but like when i do the
fight show like i oh i see and then also
i'm team caa so i got to know you know
what the other team's doing
wow interesting it's a conflict of
interest to the fullest extent and then
wme also represents some of the biggest
fighters in the world but they own the
ufc so let's say you get a movie
well wme wants to make money they make
the most
they're not a live event yeah so if you
go hey i'm out six months for a movie
they're probably not even getting the
offer yeah so like you know
anything we wanted you being fast and
fierce 19. what the [ __ ] he's like what
[ __ ] told me yeah by the way
by law your agent by law has to tell you
they have to tell you oh yeah because
yeah
so so but but i don't like the contract
i don't believe that but by law they
have to be able to abide by it or you
don't i know they don't absolutely
it can't be a law it is what it is you
have to associate you i think it's a
union thing whatever but they they they
have to if you are given a uh
um you know they can say now a role yeah
a deal like i would advise this guy
against this guy think about it if you
have a huge fight coming up or you're
gonna do a movie and they're interested
in the ufc why in the vlog would you be
represented
i can't believe any fighters i don't
know why any fire is not with ca
interesting it's not about a big dog
that can fight for you like that yeah
the fighters are watching right now the
francis ingano thing yeah but one of the
biggest reasons why there's the biggest
roadblock is he's represented to the
fullest extent by ca oh they're not
scared w they're bigger well yeah
so yeah it's like you know so they're
going to fight to the death of what's
right
he's letting his dick swing full out i
mean i and i respect hillary i'm so
happy he's doing everything he's done
yeah he lost his phone oh he'd be in bad
spot and and and he fought smart he did
exactly what he should have done like
special yeah you know toyota's mtla sale
right in that fight but three weeks
before he went in that fight his team
didn't want him to fight
three weeks before the fight towards mcl
ac on his right leg so he couldn't
everyone's like he's gonna push
no so after the first round like he's
like [ __ ] i gotta figure something out
he wants
dude he did no
condition he couldn't do running
condition nothing and he went in there
with his career on the line and still
beat cyril gone so as heavyweights for
you guys for you guys i love [ __ ] like
that it's heavy you just tried to strike
you're a little aggressive with you he
just tried to strike him as has
heavyweights give me the one heavyweight
of all time that you would really dread
kane velasquez okay
yeah i'm not a wrestler you guys
probably love questions like this i
would rather i would rather fight brock
than kane real hundred percent yeah
brock you know what you know if i beat
big nog i was guaranteed brock lesnar oh
my god why why why
aren't you why brock over uh came
because of his he can't strike well kane
a's mentality he doesn't break b he had
the best cardio of really anyone in the
ufc doesn't stop yeah so the onslaught
never stops right so if anybody's going
to break his i don't know
so you'd rather fight
but you've got to break your will but
you'd rather fight canelo oh dude i'd
rather fight francis
imagine having your wheel broken that is
insane yeah well you know his whole
school's a table full of men that bobby
green's whole skull is tattooed oh look
at these boys about to throw down he
cracks me up oh [ __ ] i'll tell you what
man i hope these boys are using kratom
listen you know i love kratom and chin
loves kratom chin got me started on
kratom listen kratom is the best product
i've ever used to get focused brian all
right yeah what kratom does you ask i'm
glad you asked do you want to know that
i'd like to see that movie limitless
yeah
but that's impossible i want to be like
it's bradley
you can get to that limitless skill and
it's all natural all natural ingredients
you know what the thing is about kratom
yeah you know where cbd was like four
years ago where like everyone's like i
don't care yeah yeah yeah it's all about
educating you man
kratom's that next like cbd product
total focus because you know cbd is like
in grocery stores it's like 7-eleven
it's all over again
18. kratom's really the next thing
they've used in thailand for thousands
ahead of the curve but it's the wild
west so you need a worthy like product
to trust it's the only kratom i use chin
uses we're talking about happy hipple
herbals all right happy hippo herbals
okay you know what i'm saying and if you
use the promo code thick boy with three
c's that's
t-h-i-c-c-c boy you get 20 off the best
kratom on the planet the only kratom you
can trust only crater my use before
every stand-up show every podcast it's
my limitless pill the secret is out
you're welcome happy hippo herbals.com
thick boy is the promo code 20 off or
you weren't here happy hippo herbert
and because you were the last person
here we've already had this conversation
you're always late and it's fine but
you're always late but i want you to own
it but you're always playing
i don't know trading what dolphins you
[ __ ] hey man
i know i know what it sucks [ __ ]
saying i'm an artist i'm an athlete bro
you're not an athlete my body will do
whatever i tell it to do you said that
once to me and i stole it wow he does he
goes my body will do whatever i tell it
to do i like that you can't never forgot
that i went that's how you that's how
you define an athlete and i've used it
on myself that's how we go i've said it
to people i've gone well my body will do
whatever i tell it to do i've said it
but not a room of like real people oh
bubba come on like all the bikers
i was giving guys boxing lessons the
other day but nobody was around you know
better hey so check this first of all
did you see did you see buffer suit
jacket tonight
buffer shoe jacket is [ __ ] killing at
the game tonight it's fantastic um so
that's the first part second part oh
we're gonna miss it now it's shame it's
it's killer it's absolutely fantastic
second part is uh there's a dude that
we're friends with down in florida right
and um
and he
he um he was sick he has he has a
sickness we had to go to the doctor and
um
no like six like now like i'm sick i
stopped guessing um
and we had to and we had to go to the
doctor right and so we went to the
doctor and the doctor was like he's like
hey man he's like he's like what are you
he's like the doctor was like what are
your activities like what's your
physical exertion he's like um
matthew here is a professional athlete
i'm probably 80 of what he does on a
regular basis and i was like what the
[ __ ] like i was so offended on the
moment i was like no [ __ ] dare you
say that that's annoying oh dude i was
so salty like how dare you put yourself
after like 80 of my conversation oh dude
i was so salty like sorry is that that
made me think about that conversation
brandon brennan i'll do that we'll have
i'll have a buddy and he goes my buddy
go i ran at four or five in high school
and brennan goes no you did yeah yeah
yeah
dude right yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah i don't know he does finally kids
that's what it is he's my future on the
road and then now he said i met him did
i meet him in annapolis
no that was derek poston who's also a
beast he opens for schultz and rogan now
okay
schultz is doing really well right and
he's got married right yeah yeah yeah
good for him elsewhere we got poked in
the already hey so is that should that
be a point you just got pokemon that
should be a point should i be a point
yeah you know they hit five different
things hey chris are you ready i don't
know
i don't know if you can get this
reference you have to bring this up
mitrione is the bat off uh fern gully oh
wow played by robin williams and he's a
crazy he's a crazy bat and he has bolts
in his neck and he's just insane that
was impressive bro dude that's matt to
it
because he says he has a million ideas
because you're kids
no i guess that's my favorite when you
were a kid oh wow look at bobby it's
avatar avatar copied fran gully chris oh
the exact same problem
okay chris chris bobby's good at
standing on the edge of the pocket dude
shut up you know what i mean he was the
coveted mvp when they were fighting abu
dhabi he fought i think he won like four
fights
why don't i know bobby is he canadian
because that's a canadian
fighting forever he's a good he's been
fighting forever man honestly the guy on
the right has a bunch he just looks like
some guy that was that would i think so
oh no one's listening okay sorry no no
no it's okay i'll get like chris tell me
again real quick nah it's not even
really that important
it's funny he got it back hey he got
poked in the eye i know he poked him in
the air he just looks like a guy that
would work at a t there said it [ __ ] yes
dude you can't take it back
and you can't take it back it's out
there
well come on he'd be like what phone
plan you want yes i did another one dude
you can't take it back that's alive
the ref looks like a hell's angel yeah i
know and he's actually the nice guy in
the world i know you have to be the nice
guy in the world you look like that you
have to be or you can be like enforcer
for that he would have been dead he
would have been dead though you've got
to be nice beltran has his beard tucked
into his shirt right now they made him
look because he was becoming a
distraction they said they made him they
made them really yeah
you know what they do is just tie it
behind his neck yes that would be the
[ __ ] that would be amazing like
a bluetooth headphones
or like when you're skiing with your
sunglasses
you know um bobby green reminds me of
michael johnson
i don't know who either no no you know
who he is he's like michael johnson the
first one
and uh crazy foreign how'd it be hell
yeah hell yeah that's such an old
reference
jesus christ he's have you ever trained
there was a knight no oh he came to
jackson's right after me yeah and
they're like he's insane oh dude you
know he really is there
he knocked somebody out in the gym and
they kept him to chill out and he
knocked the guy out and the guy went to
his car and got a crowbar and tried to
attack him oh he's just he's he's
insane dude he was he was great wow
great choice uh charles was great when i
met him a handful of times
um but rashad is great friends so maybe
they have like some kind of relationship
where he was like hey man you you
you're in a room with killers right now
like but i don't think charles would
care if charles decided to act up no but
he was he's always been [ __ ] dope
every time i've met him i've always been
really crazy hey dude yeah by the way
josh barnett texted me today he said
what's up oh really yeah i [ __ ] love
you so he doesn't know it yeah he
doesn't know i have a secret crush on it
he's so dope dude like um he has a super
bowl party tomorrow otherwise i just try
to get up that's who he wears
flashback fights with them like so
slightly
his flashback fights would be insane
dude oh my god that what a good call
what a good call i can't hate when i'm
missing no i'm still here no it's all
right thanks dude
what about fern gully oh somebody's
bleeding somebody's fault oh no you're
talking he's just so gay man come on man
that guy's like you didn't get the right
phone plan my wife just told me i had to
fix my hair and we're going out tonight
so don't get hammered matthew look look
look fair point thanks oh and this is
the best advice for you for fighting man
long show long show oh yeah yeah dude so
you're gonna wanna yeah
we're chilling and we're having a good
time and i was just about to say
something wasn't i love it i know that
was just about to take out the grenade
no you know what i'm not gonna pull out
the grenade because i'll tell you right
now we've been we've been doing this a
lot yeah i demerit you every week right
hey man dude no no i'm gonna try a
different time
what are you gonna do now
look out
oh there you go dude the oops grenade
doesn't drop in a week i'm giving you
something
no it's very nice dude better not be and
i want to reward you for being a good
friend and maybe you'll learn that way i
like it it's not a shitty gift it better
not be a shame open it
you take too long with them you have a
lot of outfits no
because i could ruin the benefits
you take too long timing it's everything
okay so open it quicker you couldn't
just untie the knife it's okay don't be
nervous
dude my son opens stuff better than you
do he's not too young hey but it's good
paper look how heavy the paper is very
good dude you did not since you
interrupted me i thought i'd get you a
gift
[Music]
there's a few extra o's in there what do
you want me to do with this you piece of
[ __ ] hang it up above your bed
i'm not doing that and kiss it before
you go to sleep no dangling off your
tesla
yeah
dude whoops i don't have anything or or
we'll put it back there no i'll do it oh
you know what you should do what
whatever you're wearing put it here i
won't do that dude and be oops man
flavor flame it because you're oops man
doctor interrupted yeah that's who you
are you want me to wear it like this oh
yeah okay so everyone knows when you
walk up they gotta be quiet all right
gonna [ __ ] up i heard you okay first
time you piece of [ __ ] all right
putting it right here it's hilarious
who the [ __ ] made this that's a nice
it's it's actually i've got a crafty
fiance
oh dude she's doing arts and crafts when
we were doing the show exactly that's
all she goes are you into painting i
went what
brought her she was she's like i gotta
go on stage she was painting behind the
merch table just painting [ __ ] in san
diego she was doing the same thing she's
like you down to pain i'm like
no no
she told me she told me i was actually
like
she told me that she was like i asked
brandon to paint it was so funny and i
was like oh yeah what do you say she's
like i don't know i gotta i don't know
maybe later
i was like i know he doesn't want to
well you don't want to be like me like
no right i was like maybe let me uh i'm
going on in five so i'll come back and
yeah if you have this stuff dude
he is straight through that yeah you
gotta root for that straight to that
high guard man he is going right through
it hey that's what i did
dude anytime you want bro i'm pretty
sure the camera i'm surprised he hasn't
done that i'm surprised he hasn't done
that straight left to a right uppercut
it's a great fight to kick off the i'm
pretty sure that's for sure oh cameron
and he's so active matt tell them about
we were talking about guys like crazy
guys that fought in the ufc or built or
whatever right tell them about the
hitman ready tell them about the working
hitman who couldn't get a visa to come
over to america because he's busy
killing people in england
he got he booked a fight in america and
our government was like well no well no
no because this is in the movie the
professional we can't have it so this
dude
i was supposed to fight him in 2012.
um i just lost my first fight it was a
check congo i lost him in october of 11.
and then
um my next fight is there any more money
more muscular than czech congo yeah
francis
[Laughter]
that wasn't a legitimate finish um so
then so then um i'm supposed to fight
him sometime in 12 and uh and it keeps
getting delayed delayed delayed and i
was like what the hell is going on i'm
like well dude it's a hitman he got
caught for being hit man he's a hitman
in london in england he's a hit man in
england for like the british mob and
like
part of that and they were like they're
like well he was supposed to come
through and then once he applied for the
visa to come over there like
not so much is the reason why and they
shut everything down and that's why rob
broughton never fought in america how
crazy is that because he is he out of
jail or is he we probably shouldn't be
speaking so liberally no no he likes us
he might kill us yeah no he might kill
you i mean you're the one talking
so you know what that's from right the
hangover yeah that's the one
the original character was supposed to
be russian right i don't know he was
supposed to be from new york a guy who
talks like that and brian brian
freestyled it yeah well i said to him
was that the one you're in the strip
club no that was the second one same
thing
hello and so then what were you on the
third one
i chose not to be why'd you go oh [ __ ]
well what happened dude i thought well
she didn't do good job no i did too oh
yes
yes i did there were other guys in all
three right right you know it's the same
castle do you know what's sad about that
the second one is i i kept leaving it
was for an indian guy and i kept leaving
messages for todd phillips as an indian
and finally called me and goes dude i
can't put you in a movie it doesn't make
sense
i get a call
saying hey dude can you be in thailand
in three days because this guy's not
working out that's right i go okay let's
maybe come up with a character i go okay
i'll come up with a character i've got
15 different accents all these bad
things he's he heard all of them on set
yeah and he goes
i don't like any of this he goes just do
that old accent and i go but they'll but
they'll know it's eddie and he goes
because it might they darken my face
and they go i was watching blackface by
the way right
i don't want to i was so excited i muted
myself
the biggest sequel of all time and you
think they're going to be thinking about
you is your character going to throw my
movie off yeah i was so [ __ ]
embarrassed
in front of everybody you know brian
lies about knowing people and [ __ ] like
that and then i was at a party with todd
phillips yeah and he beat he sees me
across the room beelines to me todd
phillips todd phillips he did the
hangover director he did uh the wedding
crashers yeah okay one of the biggest
strikes of all time okay i could get
into it why i know that stuff but he uh
bee lines cuts through the party i see
him come like that's [ __ ] todd
phillips i've never met him and he goes
you do a show with brian callum right
mike sure do and we talked about you
flacking out he's like you [ __ ] tell
him i love him oh wow yeah he said you
tell him i miss him i love him i love
talking about yeah if you're such good
friends call them um yeah i'm here for
the gang bang
that's him that's him yes but he's the
okay he's the creator director i i
didn't know that i i just know him from
her face
the connection yeah bad santa you're in
bed santa the connection his agent who's
been with him does he make a cameo like
stan leader and everything yep so his
agent who was has been with him since he
was 21 is one of my best friends really
yes todd todd feldman okay who also runs
ca he's a cool [ __ ] guy
he's a true friend and a great person
i sent him
todd feldman is a guy you can count on
like as far as a friend like he's a
special dude he's a [ __ ]
there's there's two people i talk to
everyone sound a little gay but every
damn jesus christ and i first i get on
my knees and i pray the lord and savior
elon musk and then i uh i talked to todd
feldman every morning before coffee i
talked to him for an hour and a half
rogan after i drink my coffee for an
hour and a half that's three hours you
talk to rogan every day damn there
attack at least tax but usually i would
say call like action on the phone two
three times a week tax every day what do
you guys talk about
not just their lives
i just i just told brandon i was like i
think for for some reason
hear the story right and first of all
it's in new york rogan's doing a giant
venue okay right take it from there so
like so kayla and i were in buffalo and
uh and i hit him up like hey man we're
in town if you have so much tickets i'd
love to go to your show whatever else
he's like yeah he's like i'll put him on
the thing for you whatever he puts us
front and center 10 rows back [ __ ]
great seats perfect seats right awesome
kill us go to the bathroom right it's a
it is a full full house
okay let's go take a [ __ ] yeah she had
probably hey man you know she had to
poop
so we had we had to sneak out so we go
out in the middle of joe said so joe
gets on maybe for five minutes and it
was like uh i think joey i think joey
opened four days yeah joey diaz is open
for him and then some other dude yeah so
he's a hotbed of the girl crying ian
edwards joey diaz yeah yeah and then you
sat through all that and then you're
like and then joe's not saying and then
she's like dropping like she got i have
to drop a deuce baby so so we get up we
split and i don't want to be rude i
don't want to be rude and go interrupt
the set again to go back in the seats so
we stayed in the back and we never went
back but i didn't want him to be like
hey like these [ __ ] walked out
in the middle of my house
so for me like
i am genuinely
i'm uncomfortable like i think joe's
like i would be kind of salty if i
notice that meal i say and then a
[ __ ] didn't come back and i
might go like i would [ __ ] i would
definitely if i could be tickets and
then you [ __ ] buy something
get up and leave i'd like what the [ __ ]
right but joe did you tell me on
so i like for like the last four years
i'm like the [ __ ] are so salty
like like like literally every time i
see him i'm like do that [ __ ]
because i talked to joe this morning and
then i was talking about matt's like
yeah dude i don't think he likes me
anymore he told me that's where i went
i'm telling you he didn't see he said he
just brought it up one day
there's no way you don't see it yeah i
even like i was even going to text him
when i was like dude i think i think i
was so uncomfortable i actually erased
his numbers so i never texted him why
would i have to deal with it
like i was so because i think because i
know like i would take that [ __ ]
personally because somebody if i got
somebody's like hey man let me do this
and i'd do them a favor they gave me a
ticket or whatever and then like and
then they bounce a million dollars
next time we're hanging out i'll just
put you on stage before i go on so you
can look out and you you'll be like oh
he definitely well hold on you can't you
just didn't do that right so it's okay
it's in his head
like
it's just like acting like he did it
joe doesn't think about that let me ever
ever talk about every morning talked
about when his head hits the pillar he's
like this [ __ ] miss room
it's weird you mentioned that because
this morning he's like [ __ ] man you
walked on my show seven years ago in
buffalo you remember that i'm like yeah
neil young neil young and [ __ ]
manager two
bobby green is lighting this kid up it's
crazy yeah bobby's [ __ ] him he's so
fun to watch and you see him in that
last round then he was like right here
[ __ ] he's like meet me in the
middle it's crazy how his beard grows
like that he's got he can just
you don't want a diet huh you got wisdom
you don't want to dye your beard no
nothing in your bag just for a minute
[Laughter]
[Music]
you know how i always wear hats yeah and
i did my hair today for whatever reason
it's beautiful thanks dude thank you you
got to hear god but uh
you never wear hats i've never seen a
hat i don't i i sometimes do like if i'm
out like just doing like a [ __ ] never
doing stand up a celebrity run to like
tj maxx look how quick my jab is but you
never really rock cats not really i do
sometimes but it's like i don't know
he makes me think of michael jackson
actually looks fantastic in them
bobby green is very exciting i look
fantastic in hats i have a question
about fashion you can see it okay what
is it relate to it the gif off uh
do you just go there because i go online
yeah that's how you rock yourself and go
online i'm like i got to be in person
the online store has always been you
guys talking about fashion no it doesn't
did you see that it doesn't matter
did you see that
yeah also you never know with your size
bro yeah
our
what's funny is when i give you that oop
shirt and you put it on and you left the
shirt here i'm like we're the same size
i tried putting your shirt on
and it was fat guy in a little shirt
because it literally was a bit drift so
well it's the same size in my head right
take that
off
so bobby green right so he circles to
his left right
so he was talking to his left and uh and
uh the the ref i can't remember his
names right now um was moderately in the
way and as bobby's fighting his shoes
push him like this he's like don't worry
that happens
he just sits there and talks to you and
just matches you know every movie let's
don't forget though that's my thing
though that's my favorite references
that's why i know books you guys want to
talk
oh
i'm in the middle of uh the first jack
richard book also okay i started
watching this there's a series on rhyme
yeah i'm a reader i'm a little bit
worried
and nobody's ever said you're not smart
you're smart but i'm just saying that i
agree with them yeah no he doesn't i if
there's a show on it i'll watch a show
you know the guy who created jack
reacher was pissed that uh tom hanks or
tom cruise did it yes yeah because he's
too small because the new guys [ __ ]
yeah yeah tom cruises did jack reacher
yeah in the movie yeah in the movie
really
he could fit in my pocket i know him and
him and jane dupree are the same size
but he's tom cruise and then the creator
was the body he makes up in i'm telling
you the creator was like this is a guy
he's too small man yeah like but it's
tom cruise it doesn't matter like do you
want i don't like honestly i i don't
like anything like that in hollywood
when they try to make the guy look like
the person in real life i don't like
that i know jack reacher is a fake
person but like when somebody when like
ben casey play gandhi like dude just
[ __ ] get anybody to play it doesn't
matter it's a it's fictitious it's no no
it's not the action thing
i know that's what i'm saying you dumb
[ __ ] listen oh okay listen then you
won't say things okay don't like you
just said okay but i'm not you're you're
not my teacher so don't do that then
don't make me be one okay no i that
sucks education sucks education don't
put yourself in a dumb box i'm
but i don't have to be your teacher
right okay right certainly yeah that's
right you [ __ ] okay so all i'm saying
is don't put yourself in it
dumbbox
right because then i've got a school you
know
i don't like that you're being super
disrespectful dude remember that whole
like dramatic pause thing you just crush
it right there thank you thanks we
talked about that before yeah yeah well
he's delivered brain damage he's one of
the most exciting fighters can you can
you imagine the patience you have to
have to get your skull to you you know
he i think his brother passed away in
the ufc covered the the funeral class so
he's like you'll never hear me say a bad
thing about the ufc they help me when i
need him dudes [ __ ] i i like dancing
i like dana
i like daniel i you know i would after
what i heard what he did today i
i love dana white yeah what do you do
today
i can't it's not my story to tell yeah
it's rogan's it's not my story to tell
but i will i do i i will never talk to
you
again the moment i heard it i was like
abs are [ __ ] losing that's not my
strategy i'm on that dude's list can't
wait to hear it off there or he's on my
mind though and you won't
oh tell me i saw dana white in a club
and never flipped them off yeah so so i
think so so
so this is right yeah for sure yeah can
i make really good decisions in my life
yeah so um i mean hey talk about that
can i get a white call please um
we are are you rushing for a frat or
we're in excess
and in vegas and uh we have that place
that plays [ __ ] rock all right man
that's that's the point [ __ ]
you've been there though you were there
right
now hold on bro come on come on man
i don't know dude there would that be in
them so we're next we're in vegas yeah
and we're partying whatever yeah thank
you very much
and we see um
uh we have our uh we got booth or
whatever you know yeah and then above
our website
is dana's booth and i didn't know it
until i turned around and i see dan i'm
like oh [ __ ] there's dinner dinosaur i
give dana the finger right but i'll
cross the room he goes like this right
just give dad a thing and he looks back
[ __ ] you he's like come here so i come
up and see him now i have no hard things
against dana whatsoever i just saw him i
just left ufc i was in bellator i was
making way better money i was happy my
life was good you know i think i might
have just beat fedor um
so my life was great at that time yeah
right and and he's like come up here man
so i come up there he's like why'd you
give me the finger i was like i was just
[ __ ] with you he's like dude
i won't tell anybody this at all he's
like but good for [ __ ] you he's like
you just won the game he's like he did a
great job he's like we tried to we had a
leveraged position we tried to work it
and you went and you made your own money
and you you you you believed in yourself
and you made money out of it he's like
good for [ __ ] you're respected yeah
yeah like you're not i said he's a
businessman as an alpha there was
nothing that was salty about it at all
he was literally a good on you man you
believe in yourself and you had sex
let me tell you how much
matt doesn't give a flying [ __ ] about
fighting and he never has he beat fedor
i was working the fight for bellators my
first big fight i worked for bellator
math square garden for passing out
flyers uh i was selling hot dogs but um
get your hot dog
when they get in the ufc it sure was if
these hot dogs are a real knockout you
see anyways so he uh knocks out fedor
yeah and i rush in the back because
matt's my boy i'm like bro you [ __ ]
knocked out vader i'm grabbing like you
[ __ ] knocked out a legend he goes
what happened i go wait what he goes
what happened i go
um
you you guys both hit each other and you
sprung up and you knocked them out and
just that's cool man i'll see you later
i was like oh yeah all right man yeah
that's stupid this is cool he just he'd
rather hang with him and and he's like i
get a hot dog
dude wow yeah that's how i'm six too
dude you know what you you're ramrod
straight aren't you i'm ramrod's right
there yeah yeah scoliosis [ __ ] fix
that thing how about one ultimate
fighter right i knew fighting yeah we're
sitting there and they're announcing all
the fighters and roy nelson walks in hey
hold on yeah story we're talking ink
sorry i'm good oh you have no inks no
i'm getting a sleeve
oh yeah well
let's not go from zero to sleeve though
i agree
zero to [ __ ] boom hey so zero
different story zero to sleep i made my
entire career with no tattoos and i've
always wanted them always
i just i did i never i liked being a
fighter with no tattoos i like being an
anomaly versus the other group sure and
then when i got done kayla got hers done
done his due to miami named uh alejandre
molandre yeah
doesn't matter
i doubt it rhymes i just want to go
ahead
okay
i mean at least make a better effort no
no no i like allah he's like some cuban
in miami
he's he's a really creative artist and
he did carelessly you know what i want
you to do mine i know i got the guy for
you daddy smith out here and this dude
was like he's like this all he does is
like major uh major like multiple day
tattoos i don't think you know what what
are you gonna get have you thought about
it
but the bad part is there's they don't
um they're not together i love uh i'll
show you i'll show you my ideas but like
just spit off some ideas so we can run
through it with the team here okay so he
has a necktie so you're in a safe space
but you're being you're being stupid i
love it but i want another super oopsy
right now because i need to hear oh
that's what i'm saying i want to come
here
so he's very lipsy right now
yeah
i'm trying to let him get through
because i'm trying to get him to tell
the tattoo okay okay so you're
borderline you guys are what the [ __ ]
like so my position is i grew up in
illinois i spent most of my life in
illinois and indiana so i want the
outline of the two states
right and i want the room for
springfield to purdue i don't like this
um it depends where it depends where do
it right well so so that's right about
the route like you do you want like the
sign that says like route 88 no no i
want the like the little the actual way
you're going from springfield okay well
that's a line that that's a squiggle
line don't worry about the idea
hey hold on matt that's a squiggle arm
that's a squiggle on your
what's the rest of the idea okay well
there's a there's a like a a line in the
middle right
that's the crack your ass you've got the
cheat stops on each cheek and the
squiggly line goes
dude your capital is you're right
illinois
it doesn't it doesn't it's it's not it's
not uh
have you ran this idea with your girl or
the tattoo yeah something you don't ever
want to tell a girl about it i love i
love that picture i love elephants i
love that picture okay but there's no
elephants in particular
you get the two horns like this and the
trunk is your [ __ ]
dude squiggle line on your anus and a
[ __ ] elephant on your [ __ ]
i'm gonna attach to a placement [ __ ] you
are dude you might be like oh
you got the 40 oops right but
what happened was he knows how to place
him right
and you know you're you're an amazing
player he did right underneath the beard
line so there's no interference yeah
there's no interference yeah
i'm still too [ __ ] to do it and if
there's any interference that's all
wisdom
it is
wisdom here i got a few little
characters no no no i got a few little
gray things peeking out like oh but we
know some [ __ ] i'm gonna wait until more
successful
hey but this picture for your kids would
be dope but you're going to have to yeah
that's what you're doing
oh do it on your chest brian get a
tattoo
just
[Applause]
well you don't meet elephants right you
just kind of see them
because if you say hi how you doing to
an elephant what's it say back nothing
it gives you a peanut butter yeah there
you go so it's not really meat have you
been to thailand i tried on that because
you can [ __ ] them in thailand and then
you meet them you gotta be real tall
four dollars that's the weird part you
gotta jump up by the way i feel like
when you forget your tattoo
i went no i was only in bangkok okay
interesting time
um because i was in pattaya and paty is
[ __ ] nuts oh you've been there yeah
it's nuts [ __ ] insane that place did
they run away and call you godzilla oh
they
you know wood
my big old guy no that's ed uh big old
bald has a list oh yeah
he was in the corner yeah he might have
been no he went in the corner but the
black guy was yeah it was for the story
yeah well anyways so
what was with this woods 420 pounds 24
20 420 still life yeah apparently
coveted
we're
motherfucker's feet are so big it blew
out a flip-flop because it he had so
much edema
i'm worried about so what happened what
happened with him in ladies
shut up man what happened with lady boys
in thailand and him uh well there's a
lot of ladybugs you know what the funny
part is you might know i heard it's hard
to decipher if they're too good-looking
they're lit they're they're dudes
they're too good-looking am i right hey
you know what i'm saying listen
listen
i'm there i'm there with with brodie
stevens the labrador stevens yeah and
and zach galifianakis and we're all
right take it easy and i know and this
this lady boy came up and started
touching buddy did you guys know he's
laid away from this job and i said yes
i said i said brodie i go brody listen
to me and look at me right now you take
that
female home
you're not gay that's a girl right yeah
that's all you guys knew that is that
the end of the story yeah it's okay
i ended up taking her home oh i know so
and i'm guessing he saved the story he
saved the story when he went to church
he saved this we had a weird rule like
go down every dark alley and and and
patio go down every dark gallery only
good things
there's some dope clubs and [ __ ] in
there yeah but we come out of the alley
and there's just one bad [ __ ] uh little
tiny black dress big ass big no big ass
is in thailand right yeah she turns the
corner like holy [ __ ] we kind of hurry
up catch up to her and we'll be like hey
man like what's up we started firing on
her a little bit and i'm like are you
i'm sorry you're firing are you here
you're talking about i'm sorry
i don't know
i grew up rich are you a lady now or
you've you've always been a lady yeah
and she's like bo blanche you guys my
hand were drunk [ __ ] up yeah she's got
my hand she steps up her skirt and she's
like do you feel a dick do you feel a
dick i'm like i don't think so right so
like uh and then my buddy takes her
number right i didn't feel it i would
know yeah yeah right right but he takes
the numbers like it's something there's
a number and then yeah so then uh we're
leaving the next day but we had like we
left at like 8 00 p.m so uh we were
sitting in the hotel lounge and he's
like i'm about to go smash yeah i'm
gonna go that's what i'm gonna do and
he's like
wireless yeah i'll go with you so that
way you're not walking into some [ __ ]
things like but
something in my brain tells me that's a
dude like i don't but then i'll see you
were there to watch right right right
because i'm following the story you're
there to watch it and
yeah because i either want to watch
because of horniness or interestingness
right
you don't want your buddy walking into a
situation where it loses his kidneys
that's right that's right oh that
happens in thailand yeah yeah so so we
we call he calls her up and she's like
yeah no problem come meet us over here
so she get this intersection where she
lives at uh we go over there and she
walks out it's like a um if you can
imagine like an h right like uh building
building and stairs in between right so
that's what it is nice um so she walks
out into the middle of the h we're in
the parking lot and then she starts
walking up we walk up and so she's
always ahead of us right okay
i have a huge heart on right now so we
go into the room right and uh we see
where she goes we get in the room you go
in there and all your pants are on i
walk in first because to get a good seat
because i wanted to see what was i want
i felt uncomfortable i needed to break
the door down with my body and
and
his dick was just swinging out in the
open oh boy the dude oh my gosh all the
time yeah long hair bra fake titties big
hands swinging everywhere yeah and i was
like that's yeah i'm out right yeah
yeah i think you guys and how much i was
like but how much though but how much
let's talk about it real quick yeah but
how about all you have to do
all you have to do is [ __ ] pay for
something
yeah go ahead and tuck that in tuck that
in and we'll just pretend that didn't
happen now
that's a huge clue
there's something rather controversial
that they that i may have read and maybe
know so you you know how you went
there's something about this you know
something like that wait hold on let me
queue up my thoughts are you talking
about your spidey sense it might be
you're talking about your [ __ ]
spidey sense it might be that men have a
different different temperature in to
their skin so when you touch them you
don't know it but you're picking up on a
different temperature really you feel
dead how about this
they smell differently there's a
different scent oh yeah there's a
different pheromone pheromone and you're
not picking up the females i'm so sorry
that's embarrassing i thought i got rid
of that app what happened it's the
boring alert
dude it sucks dude just because i said
pheromone and temperature i was out too
but dude that was scientific i i i
understand it okay man so the app is on
just always in the background that's my
location can't help us that app is super
rude
boring things like pheromones it's like
serious yeah you know yeah it just goes
off
i was involved
hey but did did did she smell like
flowers and peptide or um she uh i i
honestly that's racism
i was really curious
and i was like man i don't really know
how to handle this thing so i made him
come in i was like look what you made me
do and he came in and he's like
i'm not going to hit that and we left
yeah wow
but but so we were close we had a close
encounter it didn't happen it wasn't
consummated now i i did hear there are
like like bars in thailand where you
just you can you can grab bears with
your friend you just get sucked off
under the table uh that would be japan
that's typically i think japan i don't
know sure
why do you know what you don't know
there's a place you don't think the
other place is in thailand
because i have a friend who very close
friends
these poor girls like
they're like crawling on their [ __ ]
hands and knees yeah it's crazy
in a strip club now one of the strip
clubs you go into
and i think it's in the movie but
hernandez fights
the ceiling is glass and everybody and
the girls are wearing skirts with no
underwear oh and so you look up and see
the glasses i never do that but the
point is we're talking about being gay i
spent all my time in the strip
with that one nope look at this that was
a gay man huh yeah where is this where'd
that come from his little twink came out
and was like i got the cupping done and
then he apparently said on the phone
yeah i love you and you talk about his
dick yeah i know what do you guys think
of cupping is this always his demons
uh i did cupping on my uh hamstring i'm
not sure okay i don't know that now that
is a hell of a tattoo that guy's got oh
he's just looking at his neck
chris do that he's chris
yeah but
the thing about that was apocalypto yeah
but the thing about that is yeah it's
gonna look very uh like dated another
movie reference one day it's going to be
dated i don't know if you commit to that
reference
it's a great movie i have this i have
something here
are you going to get something
the best right
when did you start getting them i was 36
or 36. i'm too old to get something
when i knew who i was i knew who i was
so i don't have any [ __ ] stupid ones
okay
and now i'm just going to open up the
i'm just going to posit the question
okay
do you have stupid ones from a long time
so me have some very stupid
so now who's got a point right i'm down
to here and then this is full sleeve and
then i'm doing my leg now you're doing
your legs yeah now why did you decide
not to do your left bicep left upper uh
i just like to look that's the holy
grail it's not like just
yeah okay and then inside you have
inside here yep like a dope ass tattoo
or stan smith he was on uh the kat von d
show oh he's like the top by the way she
moved to indiana by the way i know she
sold a lot of [ __ ] and moved in and i
heard she's a little crazy now yeah
that's cool she's phenomenal money money
and tv will do that too yeah she has all
the money yeah she bought like a
whatever 30 million dollar mansion out
there yeah i don't know he gets in
minneapolis you know we have money like
that in indiana
matt i think she bought indiana yeah
yeah yeah do you ever think about moving
matter you're you're stuck you're still
i'm not for for seven more years i'm
there okay
hey tell them where you want to move i
want to move to uh well very specific
three locations go ahead uh i like how
you know yes get ready for the gulf
shore of alabama okay okay
i want to go uh northern south carolina
or southern north carolina okay uh i
want to be i want to be close enough to
the ocean but also have mountains yep um
i want to have a blue mountain doorsy
more
know you want to what uh i have land yep
and i want to have a lot of uh
really present really pretty uh bisexual
southern belles how are the how do they
go how are the school systems in those
areas
my kids my kids will be and do people
have teeth there
doesn't matter doesn't matter no
older yeah can my my kids will be 18. my
daughter will be by the time you do it
by the time you do it go on by the time
you do it oh okay you're going to wait
till they go through the school guys
you're going to do it
that's nice i can't wait to tell what i
respect about matt since i've [ __ ]
known this dude for how long have we
known each other a long time long long
[ __ ] time
just on the show
just a monster of a dad even when we're
on the show you and i connected
because i've always been so into kids
even on the show you're like i get the
[ __ ] i don't man my babies i remember
you always saying my babies my babies
everything was my babies and my baby
like that shut up now i have kids
yeah i was like oh [ __ ] matt's just
his beast of a dad matt you said well
last time we talked about your kids that
you didn't want your son playing
football yeah correct oh whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa cause he has
news to me yeah does he have your
genetics is your genetics um well better
what if he's a better why
don't say ct because the odds are not
going to get it right
i won't say it i'm just saying no but
look at the odds i'm just saying though
what do you want him to do i feel like
well
they both play football now um but
tackle it's uh yeah tackle and how old
are they um uh jacob is 16 jonah is 12.
big kids
no
jacob is uh jacob is probably five ten
uh 155 pounds now something like that
right he's he's going to be he's he's a
sophomore year now so second half of
sophomore year
he's a sophomore he's not bad he's not
bad um and he's kind of coming to his
own now he's starting to like become
more confident whatever else
he's always wrestling he enjoys
wrestling he enjoys the one-on-one
competition i'm listening i'm getting
food right on and then um
jonah is itty bitty jonah's
might be five foot tall right now maybe
they're not gonna be there uh 88 pounds
okay could have a growth spurt but yeah
if you you know those people like
innately you're just an [ __ ] like
that little kid right there like he'll
they'll break some kid he's the one he
and your which is what you need he can
do he can do whatever he wants
my athlete might be my little girl
who how old and she's dude she's
probably five three
uh hundred five pounds dude she's a
gangster did you do any other sports
besides football what did i miss brian
i didn't wear these that was nice i
didn't want to get stepped on right so i
didn't wear them out last night i wear
my flip-flops out i pulled every chick
in the club last night in your flip-flop
in my flip-flops and i was like and i
was was like your wife was like brendan
no she wasn't she said anyone's sleeping
because she was tired
so i was like brendan said i literally
thought this i was like man i'm gonna
have a rough night tonight because
brendan said fashionably i can't wear
flip-flops with pants so actually in my
mind last night and then we went to
oh you know what they're saying about
this rat they thought you were in i had
to had to they thought you're chris
brown because i i crushed it last night
you went to
jameson
bar in santa monica oh i used to love
that when i was okay so when there it
was a live band when i had flip-flops it
was
and then we left and went to victorian
victorian making it up
the hotel bar yeah but it was like it
was it was a house it was a house party
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
this is and you kind of did it right and
that's where we pulled it last night
dude like i had i was sitting down i'm
old i'm arthritic i'm dragging there
chicks come up to me you are exactly
what i'm looking for take my number yeah
oh my god you're married
yeah they thought you were in guardians
of the galaxy buddy yeah oh you know
what sandals chris pratt
when you dollop in a collared church he
doesn't prolong you but he doesn't wear
a collared shirt yes he does but you
don't want him daddy gave him you know
what daddy gave him and you appreciate
this he's not you know wouldn't he do
that at you yeah okay yeah well you call
a lot of people daddy i don't know man i
don't know but you've been daddy's look
at the table right
you know what's up anyways so um on food
truck diary every fighter gets a shoe
from suplex in philly
i got my man here the new yeezys
and he's not a fashion guy so i want the
most comfortable shoe yeah
wow like and he was like hey man he's
like i got these little somethings for
you so i put him on today walked around
venice beach today it was careful nobody
scuffed them i was careful with my shoes
today didn't step any puddles didn't
happen got your dick sucked right
[ __ ] you know full circle
and i even took a picture of me flexing
and i'm posting that tomorrow yep it was
a fantastic hey and i'll be honest the
shoes he got me he got tapped oh it was
around yeah you got tapped i hope it's
over oh look at that blood who got
leaked up like that that was that'd be a
problem
nothing worse nothing's worth when
you're jogging around the cage and you
step on warm blood remember in my head
i'd go what am i doing oh
i would like stepping on warm blood
and john madsen opened up
gay abe
abe
so this kid right you know like you
touch gloves in the start of the fight
yeah like ding ding touch yeah dude fake
the touch went in for a shot shot a
blast
held him down and
hit him with an elbow right that's like
running the lights like it's like for a
comic that'd be like like
that like we're in the light like
carlos mancillo yeah like just stealing
jesus like that yeah
doesn't leave you have a gash in your
head although
that blood was everywhere so it was it
was the worst the worst one of some of
the worst blood oh let me clean up your
mess yeah um uh some of the worst blood
i've ever seen right remember this
remember this it looked like a horror
movie remember after the fight we were
all in the kitchen because it was too
hot in the other rooms okay so we're on
the kitchen and he was getting stitched
up in the kitchen yeah and he was
talking to the doctor and we're all and
he's sitting like in his chair and
there's lights or whatever else and
they're [ __ ] hot and he goes doc
doc is my skull fracture do you remember
this no he goes down
he's my skull fractured and the doc
says no his answer no there's not he's
like how do you know you haven't x-rayed
me because i'm looking at it and takes
the syringe starts tapping it on his
skull do you remember that i don't know
dude it was amazing you might maybe
weren't in there you know abe's like
this one the smartest people of all time
for sure runs his own like software
company madison doctor from omaha
nebraska oh he's really are you serious
right now the doctor he's an ancillary
character in this [ __ ] story we don't
know
what he's doing
that's a huge word for you oh wait matt
what happened to john madison actually
you have been oh dude so you know the
story about him getting cut
about
what i want these two [ __ ] to hear this
guy that did that to abe wagner i fought
next okay and i lost the first round
horribly yeah he's all american messages
yeah he's a great wrestler like
minnesota four-time national champion
yeah first round he takes it down i'm
talking spike to him in the head yikes
not going well and then an ultimate
fight you only fight two rounds
finally wars ass out and knocked him out
got him yeah okay
and i want you to do that
he's okay
you're getting a little mouthy i won't
miss her i'm sorry all right i got it
alone
so the dude wins slander he wins three
in a row i think in the ufc because he
made it through quarterfinals john
madison yeah he's always short for the
division but yeah anybody and and he's
boring as hell he's like jacob bryan
like really really like not an exciting
fight no personality nothing yeah like
straight wrestling
right so
he's backstage he wins his second fight
and they're like hey um good luck if you
lose we're going to cut you okay and
this is go get him before he walks out
they go hey if you lose this we're going
to cut you what the [ __ ] because you're
so boring hey if you lose i remember
that don't there you go so he goes out
he wins three in a row right so he wins
this one now he's getting ready to go
for them right they give him some tough
competition oh they they no they hated
him they did not give him any favors at
all so then he's gonna look out
three-and-oh walk out to be porno hey
same thing even if you even if you're
gonna cut you have a great fight what
goes out [ __ ] wins they cut him or he
might have lost who knows what the [ __ ]
it was like a decision but then they
killed him yeah wow and then gone
like that wow that's what was that joe
imagine yeah
dude that was a [ __ ] he was a silent
assassin
you know once you've read the story
about him and me about about me and
brendan when we had to fight each other
and we and so joe silva's i remember
that we were friends i didn't want to
fight him or me i remember that i didn't
want to fight him and joe silva calls me
and goes
hey man i know this he's your boy matt
with jerome we call him he's foma at the
mouth for this fight i'm like he's he's
asking my feelings i was like asking for
this okay he asked for this fight dude
he said he's gonna knock you out i'm
like matt said that he's like yeah like
oh i just gotta take it called matt
matt's like dude i wanna do this man i
didn't say that i didn't say that
and i remember you said i'm gonna talk
[ __ ] just say take nothing i say
personally yeah we both said that we're
gonna have [ __ ] yeah it's [ __ ] crazy
it was weird like even like
for like a bit of time afterwards it was
it was [ __ ] weird at least you and i
yeah
for me for me it was weird just because
like it was like such an all i can't
fight people i care about i just can't
yeah no i've i've always been too nice
my coach was like you're too friendly
man you're never gonna even in practice
i'd watch by the way how about trevor
[ __ ] whitman right now what kind of
run is he on blowing up
yeah marty left going down to florida
because he was supposed to fight gilbert
and they're both in the same camp uh
gilbert burns yeah and so to fix it he
was like because they were going to do
night morning and night training oh so
he's like i'll just get out and henry's
like i'm not going to corner one person
tomorrow night training with trevor
we'll do and then plus with rose and
then with gacy like he's coach of the
year and it might be whatever the [ __ ]
that means but like henry does a great
job and don't get me wrong i [ __ ]
love
henry but but trevor is doing that
camaro's jab and then he knocked out
mozvador ah dang dude and and and nobody
said marty was a striker nobody said
more to striker
[ __ ] all chris talked about was how
marty had no hands yeah chris
dude i'll tell you what hey by the way
derek's with us down in florida
[ __ ] yeah there's him he's on food
trucking he's one of my favorite people
tim that's your coach the the hat
backwards with the white guy on the left
how cool that's coach henry and now that
diane dutchman now that derek's dinosaur
blonde and he hasn't lost so that's cool
dude i'll tell you what's cool
demolition is man what's cool dude
landscape is so freaking cool they
launched their ultra premium collection
man believe it or not ultra premium dude
you think man tape you're thinking
hygiene for around your private no dude
they got it all man all-in-one skin and
hair care all right they got the skin
care kit for an everyday man because
from head to toe literally manscape is
just below the waist you boys know this
now trust them with the rest join the
four million bros worldwide who trust
manscape by going to manscape.com for 20
off and free shipping but you got to use
the code cfc all right do that all right
and dude we're talking about premium
deodorant we're talking about body spray
like axe which is old school i'm talking
about body wash two in one shampoo and
conditioner you get a free gift bag all
right lip balm that'd be fun am i right
am i right yeah all right it's fantastic
right man get that ultra premium
collection hot off the shelves go to
go
get you 20 off and free shipping with
the code cfc manscape.com that's 20 off
and free shipping with the code cfc
manscape.com
whoa
are they looking like is this cool
dude this is this is the next fight
companion march 5th
this time everybody's in town chris is
in town that's cool you can cancel a
date yes i'm excited chris you and i are
performing together i'm going to uh uh
[ __ ] jump on stage for your brain
shows yeah brian that's next week yeah
thursday friday saturday is already sold
out i don't know actually actually let
me look guys are you sick and tired of
going to live podcasts in vegas at
diversion and movies
oh i've heard that place and not getting
getting the kind of show you paid for
well sam tripley and i february 19th are
going to be doing a live conspiracy
social club and then stand up afterwards
come on i can't wait i mean that's
february 19th that's next saturday dude
could you know how like the mass mandate
ends forest february i know except for
here in l.a but everywhere else in
california sacramento because your boys
do the 24th through 26th there's no
masks there's no maps they can go to the
punch line and watch you with no masks
wait you can go sit in the crowd with no
masks
in sacrifice sacramento punchline
february 24th through 26th
we know nashville's never had mask and
i'm there in the beginning of march and
then you know chicago released the mass
mandate too i'm their end of march as
well you're so lucky
i'm going to be at the american comedy
company i'm doing two shows well you
don't need the first because that's only
50 c
hey
that's 200.
small times no no no no it's fine but
you don't need to plug that you can just
yell in a coffee bean and they'll all go
you'll sell out by just yelling and
coffee
dude yeah barnes and noble
american comedy club
go to a radio shack and just hint you
might be
at the [ __ ] american comments hey uh
you'll sell it out immediately because
it's five seasons about flyers at home
depot hey guys i don't like the way this
is going man it's okay it's february
yeah he's great i love zendaya you
he's good i love him chris can i talk
you can't get real for a second yeah but
i was there's
a real joke but can i get real for a
second sure yes you know i wish king of
the sting was what i was just you me and
theo i wish we did two episodes like
real regular youtubers you wish so much
the others was on patreon be careful
i mean i'm just saying but be careful
what you wish for dude do you think we'd
sell any tickets
no idea i have no idea we might well you
know what we could do
do 900 000 shows at american comedy
company
hey yeah hey i'm just doing it to brush
up on some new stuff
dude johnny lose stuff huh
all right what's it about man
ostriches being 50 what yeah being 15.
that's an ostrich no
it is not all right i'm doing age [ __ ]
now you got to be careful dude because
you don't want to go toe-to-toe with
daddy like we did last time and then
remember the last time
and i showed you the impression
when i decided to bring out the guns oh
the no but do you remember when i
brought out the guns
right i keep my knives out all right you
don't want me to bring out
the gun no dude i don't it's not you're
not no i'm saying you're making me happy
don't we have a good night
we do have a good time i know so careful
but we don't want to get into this crazy
[ __ ] where i bring out
the gum
[Laughter]
chris it's a knife fight chris am i
crazy
or
the when we did chobin friends at the
improv last wednesday is that the
hardest you've crushed since the
pandemic
it's been to me it's the best that i've
seen thanks dude yeah it was a fun one
yeah crushed good it was a fun crowd
good room yeah but they go it's funny
because we have another one i think
february or i'm sorry yeah february
we're in february brian went up he did
fine he did good good so and then and
then when i went up after that they go
like this
brian oh no no no i laid the groundwork
and i went hey guys you laid the
groundwork is there any oxygen left in
the room you know what you know
remember that and i stopped pulled it
short it went back
over you laid the groundwork and then i
built atlantis
hollywood.com see when the next shopping
friends is i think it's the uh like
february yeah i'll be in brea and irvine
go to chris leah.com and then it doesn't
matter i need to plug it i'll sell it
anyway okay
so why is it not that's all and i just
pulled it back a little bit and left
some we had a z's on there too huh he's
popping yeah he's [ __ ] so what um
williams is one of the funniest ones the
funniest people oh he's so obviously i
know nothing about arenas where to talk
where where comedy goes right sure keep
going
but
where is a spot like do i what's a
universal spot comedians love this type
of joint
like what shop i mean i want you to put
anything a blast i'm just saying in
general what do you mean that that like
a good good room yeah like like what
comedy works denver zombie works la
jolla honestly dude the philly here yeah
san diego
no no that room is i've been piped down
about it i've been piped down about it
it's funny it was wrong
about it yeah like he said i haven't
piped down about it yeah um no chris
well comedy clubs are always the best
but because it's just that atmosphere
that you come up in and it's like
intimate like theaters are great if you
can like pack them out sorry but um
but yeah dude i mean like
you know rooms like the this comedy
club's always best right i think so by
far yeah that's why i shot my special
because everybody's used to that like
people go
closer like it's more interesting
the laughs ricochet off the [ __ ] wall
you feel it so i shot my last comedy
special in dallas the outside that that
that's a great and i i had my boy redo
the set so you can't tell it's an improv
so you just get the crowd
on camera like when you do those giant
theaters it it's a weird relationship it
is i would never do it again in a giant
place like like we were talking about
how rogan couldn't see you in that
theater like in a comedy club you can
see the people and it's like just it's
you're looking at their in their eyes
they're telling their stories
if it was like the comedy shop or
whatever it is on sunset whatever that
place says
then he'd be like i saw you get up and
leave right right yeah maybe yeah okay
yeah could definitely yeah all right i
get it now maybe i don't feel nearly
dark but like but laugh factory improv
you'd be able to see yeah
yeah
oh my next show is this edition dude the
next show uh shop and friends with
everybody here but matt but if you want
to get on matt let me know it is uh
wednesday february 23rd at 8 pm and then
also march 9th and march 25th oh that's
already
yep
do it is it weird to anybody else that
we're a month and a half deep and 22 yet
yeah i feel like this is a lot of weird
it's always weird how quickly that
happens i'm like oh it's already like i
just remember saying happy new year
and it's like already oh really you guys
think about that
no that's the point it's like oh [ __ ]
time flies oh hold on a second
do you know what it's like how did you
come up with time flies you know what
it's like to be 55 though and when oh
you're scared huh for real like yeah
time what happens is when you get to be
in your 50s i swear to god birthday 55
no you go like this you go wait a minute
how the [ __ ] did i get here and then you
meet somebody who's your age yeah well
especially because well you especially
you guys like
somebody but there's not many of your
somebody but there's it's like meeting
somebody i'm not like you used to know
back like
i was thinking about this it's like
meeting somebody on a deserted island
that you knew back in civilization
because you both
you used to live in the future and now
you don't do the future's here nobody
wants to hear what your plans are when
you're 60. interesting it doesn't matter
it's like when i'm 60 who i don't care
16 doesn't matter
it's a weird time man but brian was also
by far the most complicated indirect
thoughts i've ever heard that was hey
your your incoherent ramblings have
that's coming forward no points five
things in three seconds
[Music]
dude i took my son to [ __ ] in this
italian restaurant today and they're
like uh do you have your vax card no
one's ever asked before in l.a they need
to for in order to sit down in your
backyard i'm like what the [ __ ] it's an
older there's older people here oh yeah
i have my back guard i show it we sit
down and we're chilling i heard my son's
food and he looks like his dad why is he
sleeping i look over and the guy's
probably 55 is all oh i do i want to do
that yeah if you let yourself go and by
the time you're 55 it's what and then
well he got up and it took no lie 15
minutes to get to the front door my son
goes you know he's five you know
daddy why is he so slow i go because he
didn't take care of his body and he
probably drink sprite like you're
drinking yup and he didn't touch the
[ __ ] spider really yeah i i had a
checkup recently my son's gangster about
this stuff he saw tom brady doing cold
baths he does a cold bath two three
times a week now it's just like brian
just like brian i love it yeah
like yeah he's gangster learn to ride a
bike like has that kobe bryant mama
mentality like we went out there i'm
like gonna be out here all [ __ ] day
man dude it was four o'clock the sun
went down at six he kept falling he was
like i'm not going inside till you
figure this out wow
dude 8 30 pm knees [ __ ] up [ __ ] riding
around by himself now you can ride a
bike by himself wow in my in my head i'm
like that is one of the best times i've
ever so [ __ ] ganked yeah but i'm like
good job dude like i don't want to know
like i don't want them aware of how
crazy is i'm like dude you're a [ __ ]
animal
well what do you mean worried about what
i don't like my dad never told me like i
was special like you know what i'm
saying so i don't be like hey you're
different like this mentality is gonna
wow you're gonna be a navy seal like i
don't put those like expectations so i
go yeah dude like you fell and you kept
trying you finally got it that's how
this goes but it for five year olds it
doesn't go like that what's up what type
of parent are you like he also doesn't
know like at jiu jitsu he's like dad why
can't i go with my friends and i would
be like oh cause they suck and you're so
much more talented than they are they
make you go to the 10 year olds you
can't go 10 or under because you heard
them so what are you doing so i go i i
go you know i go this is a numbers game
he's five
he'll be six february 21st he's rolling
with 10 year olds 10 year olds and up he
can't go with under so what do you say i
tell him i go it's a numbers game so
they already have six in the stream oh
really so you gotta go with the older
kids so and he doesn't realize this i
don't put pressure on him
because in his head he's like i'm about
this wrestling this is uh jiu jitsu but
he accelerates he sells in wrestling
so when they do like they'll do
takedowns he takes everybody down he
does my my double so he commits he
commits to him oh dude explodes does
double so my kids don't commit to dude
and the coach goes you guys work at this
at home i go mm-hmm he's nice and i go
to his natural
like i had it he has it how would your
baby uh two okay so your boy's not
flaring doubles on him no okay no no but
the two-year-old is the next [ __ ]
brock lesnar okay what do you see him
yeah is he huge he's just huge hi i'm
brendan's son yeah his hands are as big
as his mouth he's already gone
but then i i don't want to put
expectation on where they think they're
going to be like these he's got that
short touch so i just i'm like no that's
normal that's normal yeah he does have
the dick tattoo on the middle of his
shoulder by the way derek brunson works
his ass off in practice my son
completely ruined him in this fight but
let's talk about your son no if i if my
son falls and starts crying and then my
fiance would be like uh oh my god are
you okay i go
let him cry it out
are you keeping strict no i don't i
don't know what it's weird
to be bald
right no he was a heavyweight that's
what he was about a heavyweight he looks
like this guy that's a great fighter
i want that body to fight a heavyweight
fight i want that look at the guy look
at that look at the guy look at that
that's a good that's the jacket i was
talking about oh i feel you you see that
bruce boosted my commercial for my
special
this guy can do 800 chin-ups
um
do you remember
ufc
127 maybe uh in toronto when gsp fought
whoever and jake shields and he tore his
acl dude you and i were out there where
were we is that where you and i were
together for the ufc put us for the
promo
yeah is that cisco
no that's that's wesley snipes from
demolition for sure um
stop saying movies from the 90s yes
that's what i grew up on oh [ __ ] this is
a good fight
so so if jeff brunson wins this yeah
derek sorry jeff brunson a good friend
of mine play see you but um if derek
brunson wins this yeah uh he'll get a
title shot if cannon air wins i don't
think he does really canada is a cannon
there and uh has already fought which
one's kind of oh okay uh uh great the
guy in the uh i got bolted down i got
seven four white guys trying not to be
racist uh the uh blue or the one in the
uh the black choice where who's the one
four guys trying to uh
which one's there uh the uh one on the
right of the screen the one on the right
the one who's really gonna i mean no
fighting would be a [ __ ] answer who's
so the guy in blue with the blonde hair
derek
and derek works his ass off in practice
and and the winner of this is gonna be
like next
time he's a hell of a wrestler derek's a
hellfire you know what i'm saying
he's a juco
and he's fearless about it too dude
before i'm sure i'd bring it up during
the main event but robert whittaker i
was like yeah he's a good wrestler and
somebody from his camp was like hey
[ __ ] he was on the national team
that was [ __ ] wouldn't know that oh
ready for this robert whitaker won the
gold for wrestling in
in all of the national tournaments he
was picked to be on the national team in
the olympics i had no idea while he was
in the ufc in the ufc went no no dude
you can't do this
he was going to be on the olympic team
so when they say wrestling that might
[ __ ] jump into this olympic level
wrestling wrestling yeah now his
background is wrestling who do you have
in that fight i never pick against him
because if you wrestle
he's my favorite person there's two
conversations going on
nope chris never wrestled not right but
um
oh no i'll never pick against izzy and
also is he double down for joe rogan i
love you do you hear his press
conference
and he goes no we know exactly what's
going on here it's a political hit
that's my ninja do you really say that
yes i'm so proud of him no he didn't
actually say ninja
but he's the best say it chris let me
know how it goes for you yeah found this
there's only good things
yeah put that on that's gonna
not fit you and you're gonna rip it and
you're gonna be sad but look at this
watch matt try to get into that you're
285 pounds
look at how big matt when we fought you
were two
is all red
i don't know you look pretty sweet in
that thing i feel good you look good
look [ __ ] sweet it's a little tight
though isn't it on the back it looks
feels good it feels like it feels yeah
hey hey you're gonna be honest with me
because i'll be honest with you
if usada came around right now and was
like hey business cup how's it going for
you probably not going well you're
suspended hey remember that one time
people i would too there's one time
people hit underneath the cage
i knew something was going on
i heard it i heard you getting whispery
and [ __ ] you heard ruffling
listen he's trying to tell you to put
some weight on alice oh
that was a good point
jeff novitskiy was like hey hey matt
piston's cup for me let's see how it
goes you're you're spending two years
i've never had it in the cage for a
little while yeah i would i would hide
underneath this table yeah yeah let's
not talk about that hey what's that over
there yeah see you in a minute yeah i
think but god it feels good i feel funny
i do start right now you feel funnier i
feel like i feel like i just inherited a
little bit of goodness made happy made
happy i made it no no matt happy new
year oh sorry i'm sister your boy
bronson's going to win this fight
he does he's going to keep running
there's a beast yeah but he's going to
keep doing this he's going to keep
taking canon down i just feel good i
want to wear a jacket but it was 90
degrees fashion's cool it's yeah it was
90 degrees but it gets cold in here
sometimes but then when we get going
what happens
we start to sweat right here
chris have you ever worn that you know
how you wore that floral uh outfit on uh
king of sing have you ever wore
the the like joggers on stage i have
yeah what's i want to see the floor the
thing about this can i see this
the floral it's pretty lit i want to say
this
you'd work with uh do we have chet hanks
on uh
they're like chet hanks uh is it the
rapper guy
how's that going he's a good guy we
mentioned covert and he flew off the
hinges that's [ __ ] amazing yeah pants
you had a mom i'm talking about the
spark i mean
right now like i know i have it on
like hey look i'm [ __ ] killing her
chad hanks came in here
can do 900 chips he's nice for izzy he's
been he's been doing great he's been
doing great he dies
he's on the chain that's not it come on
hey uh when you grappled what yeah
that'll [ __ ] hurt for a while um when
you grappled what was your favorite
submission
oh the round throne went up oh um
i mean
you have long legs so no you never talk
are you good at trying
trouble i mean i'm like i'm not like the
submission you're a defensive grappler
were you my legs were my legs were
difficult for people but that's it
really that's right i wasn't i bet your
guard was pretty tough yeah my legs were
did you play did you play close guard a
lot i did all so i did all sorts of
crazy stuff
really man
i'll tell you what leg locks are serious
so hard though man
you know what man i did it for like five
years and i just wasn't i just wasn't
for me man i wish it was i liked what
did you like about it the company no i
liked it i just it was like i would say
it's masculine it's time consuming no
but like and i did it a lot but like
guys would just
get really really good and i would get
pretty good you know what i mean oh see
that's where he knocked him down
[Music]
legit knocked down there thanks dude
bronson's winning and then and then i
did stand up in the rest was history as
you know
uh rings you uh you've done a little bit
of grappling yes oh god she'll do a
little crap come on actually to the box
after the cold the boxing glass from
anderson silva's striking coach but
that's not grappling is it no but i do
yeah but what are you saying about
grappling i'm doing i'm wrestling a
little bit i'm doing a little great i
want to know if you had if you had done
it and if you did like what was your
what would you go to like what did you
find yourself well
right now you mean if i'm wrestling i'm
i'm known
about jiu-jitsu yeah
uh i i pulled a darce choke the other
day you caught a dark soul today were
you rolling brendan caught me in the
dark you know it was kind of weird to
watch it the other day it was the first
heavyweight dars not a big deal
wasn't the first subway darts yeah i'm
awesome
uh
pulled up if you'd like to see it it got
hit on me
so well let matt put it on you and
you'll see how it feels no i don't know
how to do it still probably don't even
not defend it really
that's his specialty
you know what's funny
i told brendan this i was like dude we
knew that was your choke and i still
didn't it's so sneaky i didn't
even practice the work but it's sneaky
it's so sneaky i think he's like sneaky
you said it four times
that get him yeah or he's better
derrick's busting his ass well that meat
that you got is good the meat that's the
other roast that's my boy i'm not a
roast beef
high quality raspberries that's on my
diet
all right it is on your diet but you're
not what are you doing right now
carnivore just just right it's getting
interesting
yeah do you know what joe's been in here
he's my nutritionist who's joe joe
exotic the tiger guy yep
i like like have you not have you been
how long has it been since you've only
been eating six weeks do you eat fish as
well come on do you ever see the tiger
eat fish oh damn
tiger time you're seeing giant joe
exotic feed his tiger's face
whatever joe exotic gives those [ __ ]
tigers before he shoots him in the head
that's what i eat
so there's a connection to joe exotic in
indianapolis so from there uh no so my
buddies jean jacket my buddy todd
mccomas um was a cop
does podcast a comedian guy okay um he's
a cop in comedian he was a cop and he
retired to be for comedy
yes okay um so great dude but he's
friends with the guy that took jeff guy
that took over joe exotic's things and
he just got arrested for for having sex
with tigers uh maybe something like that
but like there's a connection there's a
joe exotic connection
remember the show and there was somebody
from indiana like like they took over it
wasn't i think it was a jeff got with
somebody else that came in i think it
was like the financial guy that came in
and kind of got [ __ ] over oh yeah that
might have been the guy oh gotcha
something like that one of those they're
all [ __ ] dude they're all [ __ ] up
like that was such a crazy tigers it's
nuts crazy and what do you think about
carol baskin oh she murdered her husband
first do you think so oh yeah um
sardines i watched too much first 48
like this is so easy does she does she
run the tiger game but the way they do
those dogs
always one-sided really know what
happened
fair point you know what i mean like the
way like you especially making a
murderer
yes and you're like oh that guy's a
human being they did such a bad they did
why they do that guy so wrong and then
you turn the documentary off and then
you look it up and you're like oh he
killed everyone [ __ ] oh is that right
yes yeah like the cops were like hold on
you killed jfk
dude
jfk they're like this guy oh
yeah i think so i don't know if that's
what no but no but the the cops of the
town were like hold up they do like
press conference like dude we have
solid evidence yeah they make you feel
good they make you feel free to
get up they have an agenda yeah it's
such a my favorite part of that
documentary is when he was like you know
i'm i'm uh studying the law i'm gonna
get myself out of here i'm like
good luck with that yeah good luck so it
turns out he was a terrible scumbag well
i mean who knows
he like harassed her and then he killed
her in jail too right
no he's been injured oh you talk about
brendan dassey no i'm yeah i hate his
name
dude i work hard to make the name cool
who's this guy dude how about brendan's
no bread making a murderer brendan
dassetti
brendan dassey goes
brendan dassey they go he goes yeah i
was you know i guess apparently he's a
bit [ __ ] i don't know if you can say
that no then you can't but whatever yeah
you're struggling mentally yeah and then
he admits to murdering right because he
felt pressure and then goes
can i go turn my art project yeah i know
i saw that and they're like well no you
just made the murder so yeah it doesn't
matter what grade you get oh that kid
but he got he got out yeah he did
because they did that i thought i
thought i thought he had that guy i
thought he was still in no bread
brendan's out uh that's the kid that's
the guy the doctor the other guy
he was the older guy his uncle's yeah
oh my god [ __ ] oh here we go you got 40
seconds oh no
oh my god no it's only oh no i gotta
give you 900 what happened what was it
he's out oh he's out he's out he's out
[ __ ] damn oh
my [ __ ] damn it uh uh i didn't see what
happened beast
the problem is
already fought you know what's you know
what sucks is that he was
40 seconds from being done and three
elbows opened his ass up nancy get
stitches so like you went the whole
fight don't get stitches and now the
last three [ __ ] strikes
dude that was uh chris lytle my mentor
right yeah fought legend
uh fought a dude who had the the the the
arrow in his uh chest hair oh it was an
elbow that got him you got him knocked
out right there he's flashing knocked
out he's [ __ ] up oh
oh his eyes are oh he don't know about
it
i bet he's on autopilot boom
dude let's go ahead and defend that
that's elbow though huh and then how do
you do that boom
thank god that hit that right here what
did you do
oh that hurt too backfist elbow um yeah
that's so sneaky anyway so chris idol
was fighting in australia and he said he
got oh the guy with the chester tattoo
yeah yeah yeah i remember that guy
and he said that he had fun
stop it stop it
it's where they get hurt and fighting
but seriously stop the fight you [ __ ]
idiot all right what are we saying so
tim lane they found tim lane that today
committed suicide yeah did he suffer
from mental illness like depression
stuff did you work with him at all i was
in vegas a lot and you worked with him
yeah uh i know
apparently drove the mountains just
committed suicide oh no what was this
that's the word today or tomorrow maybe
they found them yeah
they couldn't access uh on foot and he
got to a peak the helicopter found him
and they're like oh what's the
helicopter doing though that's right and
what did this guy do sorry he was
actually
extreme yeah did he have a history of
depression and stuff or
you don't know
some things yeah i think there was some
things so uh some darkness and you you
like you like
again i don't know the coach that well i
know he's a great coach but i i know he
was a good dude man he was a really good
dude and dude
like were you surprised by it or did
everyone kind of see it coming oh
i can't speak on that because i hadn't
been to randy's in a long time right um
but i know that uh i know he was a good
ass dude and i think that everybody has
like you know home troubles and stresses
or whatever else sure uh and i think
that they did uh as well as they could
to kind of get through a lot of that
stuff especially when and i think um
it's such a shame i think kovad acted
upon a lot of stuff where it was hard
for a lot of people thank you if you
were actually like and indiana wasn't
coping really wasn't serious in indiana
right like
we're uh
news out there we're a hardcore red
state like it didn't [ __ ] matter if
you want to wear masks wear a mask we're
going to say wear a mask but nobody
really [ __ ] cares yesterday like the
boogeyman one of the covers yeah cool
that sounds great right but um i think a
lot of other places probably california
yeah took that [ __ ] really well because
we were north korea we still are yeah we
still are a bit of north korea still
it's got a little bit more relaxed but
it's a little bit try walking though
it's incredible like it's it's so
different from being from me back home
in indiana like
it's it's the wild west like okay great
but then again like we also have a a
drastically different belief system for
the most part yeah someone said belief
system yeah yeah who's he fighting next
prior title shot after that those of you
that's a sweaty ass dude
he'll fight the winner busy whitaker and
that's a great fight okay this next
fight coming up he seems a good dude too
i've never seen the interview where he's
an [ __ ] no me neither seems like a
great guy
that's a great win he is great jack city
dude can you imagine have a muscle like
that for no reason i would never wear
clothes i would never wear clothes
that's john crouch's coach who
was my first jiu-jitsu coach
look at that that's rob everson from wc
if you remember him the fighter and he
found the ultimate fighter that's the
guy rob everson he has head tattoos now
oh my god that's definitely apparently
his north star is travis barker there is
shawn
what's shawn like he's a great guy is he
the best
you know how you negotiate yourself yeah
he does himself hell yeah he's a beast
hell yeah um there was somebody i was
talking to
that said that
there was something they were trying to
get in touch with them because there was
something like a kid like
a sick kid whatever it was i can't know
what it was but i know the guest
terminally ill kids something's a big
sugar shot and i was like dude i i was
like i didn't know how to get in touch
with them text me dude all right because
i have to but i have to remember who it
was i have to deal with all of them
because i got to get them on the show
okay usually thanks bro oh great yeah if
you would text me i i would bet my
bottom dollar sean would fly out and see
that kid he's such a good person dude um
that's such a talent too um he he is a
a seemingly great dude every time i see
him he is he's got a great presence
about him and he's always composed i
don't ever see him super swaggy too
super swaggy and then the other thing is
he and this was talking about him is his
negotiation with the ufc which he's
doing now yeah which he should and he
he's smart as [ __ ] about what he's doing
by the way but what i told him i said
you got to realize besides conor and
like an izzy you're the most important
uh uh matt matron knocked that black guy
out in uh
41 seconds or something yeah yeah that's
cool never even touched me yeah whatever
whatever that yeah
yeah he's the greatest knockout artist
of all time in the ufc this dude he's
number one on the other hand
he knocks them out yeah i mean
yeah be cool then it could be [ __ ]
cool chris it could be the real black
beast right the black beast
yeah black beauty he changed it what i
call it what i call black big black big
black
i think it's just the beast now oh
really i think they made them drop them
that's weird
because of racism
i got crazy i got two of us on this but
what are we oh sugar shot yeah so um
besides besides connor and izzy and like
nate diaz
he's the most important athlete on the
roster because his you know he makes
more of his twitch feed than he does
fighting ufc
like he has the young audience he's the
only one the young guy that's exactly
what i was gonna say his merch i hooked
i i hooked him up with our merch company
and he sells stupid merch because he
makes more outside the outdoor than he
does inside the octagon good for him
dude i'm like so bring all those
analytics to the table when you meet
with dana white like dude this is what i
do without you guys right like you're
you're you're you're auxiliary correct
you shouldn't be making morgan punch in
the face tonight you're doing this [ __ ]
right correct yes and didn't he say that
before like he was like listen i'm not
worried about getting back in the in the
ring because of this situation because i
make more gaming
good for you like i i don't know what he
does he has his own podcast does he
really yeah you could hey man
sugar hour some [ __ ] like that good for
him does he actually uh do gaming yes on
twitch and crush again he makes more off
that stuff than he does give him punch
in the face he's good at it like but is
this his personality that makes people
he's such a person like you because
rampage likes a gaming fun i'm told he
sucks but he has twitch followers
because like he's rampant he's rampage
by the way i love
i'm surprised you you guys never fought
i was like we [ __ ] because the same
guy we're the same guy yeah you're chris
pratt that's cool what do you guys have
in this fight and your time already tell
me
a couple heavyweights who do you guys
have in this fight oh this isn't even
the last one oh this is the co-main
event but this fight's not going to go
along chris no if it does it's going to
be a night yeah you know i'll i'll be
i'll be totally honest i think that
derek lewis might knock out
that yeah i would say that yeah
i'm such a big tie too of us a fan i
[ __ ] love him how do you not he's got
a great person out have you met him uh
no he's the best you met him i just
shoot with him did you really just shoot
him
with him he's got that mitral power if
he touches you you go to sleep you know
what i'm saying um you know what he's
got he's got a hell of a personality he
whether he wins or loses you don't
really care cool tie two of us is the
same guy that's what i'm talking about
they're both the exact same i'm not
talking about that like if tai wins the
ufc is like cool same guy yeah we can't
well ufc can't lose in the fight that's
exactly right once hawaiian either one
of these two lose right first of all yes
they every every card every every box is
checked right but it doesn't matter they
win or lose they've got great
personalities they have great presence
they both go for they throw hands yep
what the [ __ ] you want yup that's it
it's just such a big jump in competition
for ty yeah i think derek's ranked three
like he's he he's beat some [ __ ]
tough dudes he has and you know what
else he's lasting he's going five rounds
like derrick we got the vocal fight like
he was getting his ass up and then
knocked him out with like 30 seconds
how's that [ __ ] crazy
i'm done with you and got up and then
knocked him out like crazy hey i'm going
to touch you when i'm talking that's
okay i appreciate it um your nationality
is um czechoslovakian and bulgarian
i can tell we have good hair
according to him that is true he's all
painting
what are you from italian and well irish
and polish yeah so i'm italian irish 50
50. wow
what are you irish italian 50 50. you're
50. my dad's my mother you take you take
more time you take more irish my
mother's 100 percent sicilian my dad
claims he claims
from dublin or his family outside of
dublin yeah yeah so you claim what you
claim you like you do you feel like you
look more irish more italian i don't
know
i don't know small and white you know um
i'm more yeah i got more uh what did you
look like when you were my dad's a big
guy you're dead six six four two so
you're adopted
you're done my mom's about two dollars
well no it's 260. yeah but i mean
structure yeah don't say 220 right well
i just mean he's
but i but i uh i take after my mom five
two yeah italian like it's for my
children my children take out to my my
taiwanese
your kids are half time yeah that
explains why they're so small yeah
quarter you know you're [ __ ] up right
yeah
that's why
if you have kids with [ __ ] this thing
i didn't mean this thing jesus christ
it's okay it's not live it's not first
of all you know you [ __ ] up about his
children and now you go this thing oh my
god do you want your wife's name
kayla actually her name is thing so it's
okay
it's kayla thinks you're actually not
bad your wife is your wife
another [ __ ] up right reverse it right
for her
just for us
does she want does she want kids
we we talk about it reverses
daddy
she's she's
if
callan gets his vasectomy reversed i'll
get mine reversed you got a vasectomy no
i didn't need i have a paper
he just had a dude have a one month old
baby
yeah any more questions matt he's 55
yeah dude he's hugh hefner you [ __ ]
come on
let's go matt yeah matt what's up dude i
can do it you can do it
you got this dime piece over with these
crazy jeans it's not it's not a joke no
yeah we were all surprised
[Laughter]
and you have a child as a hierarchy
yeah i had to tell for a couple of years
some things happen to you when the kid's
twenties he's gonna be 80
80 years they're
and uh i just did you just kept
splurting yeah sometimes it feels too
good sometimes you're just like i
grappled two days after you got a
vasectomy and my balls hurt so bad oh
god why did we do it do that because i
was like i'll be all right but it won't
be why would you show obviously a
vasectomy
you can reverse because i have
he's got three kids and he likes
splurting you know what i'm saying but
does it shoot like ducks i got that
hosie dude he he
got it snipped because he likes splurge
oh
there's two things i don't [ __ ] with
it's rattlesnakes and condoms and i'm
just trying to have a good time baby all
right well okay
so the two things you don't want to [ __ ]
with rattlesnakes encounters now going
on the worst advice ever from a dad
my kid's going to hear this because dude
like so my all his friends my wife kayla
got this like um european lingerie
modeling contract thing sure yeah so
let's picture that so she took like uh
these she did these dope ass photos do
you want to run the photos by the crew
here i was like i'm really [ __ ] proud
of those look great you know blah blah
so i posted some of them online and they
were out there for like two months
whatever they got i'm proud of you
whatever else this is my thirsty
thursday blah blah blah whatever and
like two months later jacob my oldest
son hit me up was like what in the [ __ ]
oh wow my father my child does not cuss
to me at all and do they look at her
like their mom like yeah for sure right
yeah like and so hit me like he's like
he's like what in the [ __ ] dad like why
the [ __ ] are there half naked pics of
kayla on the [ __ ] internet and i was
like
all right bro listen what's her last
name like first of all don't ever talk
to me like that again yeah i was like
okay
like just a small thai kid i was like
she got she got a contract and i'm proud
of her and she made this much money got
paid a [ __ ] time
yeah i was like so she paid bills
[ __ ] pipe it down yep and he
was like listen i'm sorry she got paid
did you do that did your kid look ty
no let him say what he was gonna do yeah
you've been upset a lot you've been
[ __ ] oopsing things up a lot i'm so
interesting about the thai kid
you keep bringing up this thai kid yeah
man and being insulting about his thai
kid by the way oh not really yeah their
quarter they're and they're not thai
they're taiwanese kids
thanks man oh taiwanese taiwanese
no not ty i'm thinking they're taiwan
hang over two i know china taiwan no you
know where it's at i know locations okay
that's not what i was thinking in my
head at all that's a great sentence
thanks man that's a great picture
i know what i'm getting from my tattoo
his family
oh that's weird is it weird is it weird
other dude's face faces tattooed on his
body like little wayne like little wayne
and like and 40 and other stuff but like
why would you get their faces tattooed
on that's weird i feel that's weird why
would you get another dude's face tattoo
on your body
you know we got a tattoo i can't think
of one
who's here is worse you'll see the guy
behind her i know where you're going
look at the guy looking at him look at
the guy looking at him oh and the flat
top yeah
so we'll see the guys here
so derek lewis called me out by name
like he beat one of my teammates years
was that okay i want to fight that mate
that matron guy blah blah blah okay and
i was in the i was in the crowd when
they called that guy said this yeah
right there he's scary and i told him i
said listen that guy said i am going to
knock you out and i'm going to stand
over your unconscious body oh like for
saying my name out loud [ __ ] you yeah
right
and i did oh wow knocked him out 41
seconds and when i knocked him out i
stood over the top of him oh you you
knocked out there
41 seconds
that is crazy how you hit you hit but
you know what's very hard well you know
what's wild is that i have no people ask
me about him all the time and my answer
is legitimately i don't know because i
was fortunate enough never to get
touched by him he didn't land a shot he
didn't grab me he didn't punch me and
touch me so i don't know what he feels
like as a fighter but i i i hit him as
kind of a weird kind of a weird
interaction that we had and he dropped
from it and then i came up with a right
hand i'm right-handed and i [ __ ]
stuck him he's on the ground and it was
like his back was against the cage and
maybe his head was too i don't know and
i hit him and it was it was like a
[ __ ] grand slam shot like i know when
i touch him it didn't it feel like
nothing i know i was like i just killed
him i just killed the jesus same thing
when i hit that dude in the boxing ring
uh when i knocked him when i knocked him
down in the second round when i knocked
him down matt fought on trailer and
fought a professional boxer yeah 18 and
three was like number nine in the world
at one point like i had no idea what was
going on uh i had no idea was that good
so i hit this dude and i hit him with an
uppercut pink and dude dropped and i
swear to god i thought he was dead oh my
god
dude and get up dude instead and beat
him and people watching my decision and
what's wow
he's got it look at this look at that
look at him he got better watch matt as
the fight went on matt you you move so
well hell yeah
look at this [ __ ] oh is that me right
there that's you beating
how was it
it's a youtube video so you can't see
all of it it's okay baby is is there
when you look at a guy like francis and
ghana because you played football spend
a lot of time in locker rooms with
freaks
he's he's
you would you say he's the freakiest
athlete to ever see no no not at all
really not even close that's a stupid
question oh you didn't even hear what i
was going to say a freakish athlete of
course no it's mark mcguire no i'm
saying in in in the ufc no no but he
looks like he looks like he could play
because you're going off
yes you're seeing defensive end you know
what francis runs in the 40
no but i would imagine probably a 5'5
but i would imagine i would imagine if
he grew up playing football he's got he
seems to have that
kind of i know but i'm saying he seems
to have that be that kind of athlete
nigerians are [ __ ] crazy athletes yes
like there is
cameroon but saying what i know you mean
well
yes yes that west africa yeah
what i mean is his ex he seems like one
of those explosives
who are we taking who are we talking
about
i just want to get i want to finish in
the first round i hope ty wins i love i
love both of them yeah but i really
[ __ ] with tai chuavasa i love tai yeah
i would imagine his personality's so
[ __ ] oh he's the best dude
him and his boy are the [ __ ] best his
boy
uh he fought in the ufc too at light
heavyweight oh really like they're like
named chin
pedro
ty
hey uh chris if i started asking for
sparkling water send me home okay
do you want another white call by the
way hey they're delicious
christian white cloth stat hey mom the
meatloaf
so vasa's looking good
this is incredible these guys wow
but to wrap that up about francis yeah
we don't know we don't know because you
know
we don't know
his speed wouldn't you say what speed is
but hold on he does have you would agree
he has crazy hand speed for a guy that
size yes or no or am i uh not compared
to a heavyweight boxer for the ufc yeah
i don't know
i'm not well but i would imagine that if
you have your imagination because he's
ripped
right right no but i would say so i
would imagine it would that kind of
because because
is he different than most other people i
would imagine yes well francis and ghana
i would imagine it's very different um
all right hold on
so so tell me somebody you feel is
comparable to french nagano and don't
say nobody you mean you mean don't don't
hold water on your hands
yeah yeah give me give me something
because there's gotta be a couple
because cyril gone was a better athlete
and he beat him i would agree with that
i don't think he's a better athlete not
even close not even close
right not
available there it doesn't mean you're
he get him i thought he hit him
the best athlete he's about the lateral
dropping you think he's what a weirdo
hey
that'll drop him okay
that's a big difference yeah but maybe
it's that's how he's he's a simone man
yeah okay well i don't mean to be an
animal i'm gonna make an argument for
that in a second but i want to watch it
yeah are you with me and matt about you
here here's what i'm going to argue with
you about that i'm ready first of all i
think he's learning i think he's got hey
did you notice that derek hasn't fought
for head position
he hasn't rolled his head that's not his
thing right yeah damn he's trying to get
him over that's it's a lot of strength
there's a lot of small strengths
when he does get him down his ground
right don't argue with him about oh it
is for sure i'm going to argue but
that's going to drain him that's the
moment
with you no no no it's not no i'm i'm an
avid fan
i pay attention
so so you know derek lowe's played
football yeah yes yes no i don't know
that high school high school never never
went beyond high school yeah well cause
i'm in jail hey hold on best knockout
artist ever in the ufc
couldn't snap
them right this guy or you injured he
inside like tripping or knee pick him
oh my gosh shut the [ __ ] up about
friends you don't know anything that's
right everybody knows his name still he
started [ __ ] talking about too much
be quiet that's what everybody loves to
talk with your mouth full let's see hey
by the way you know how much power that
was for him to get up underneath derek
while derrick was banging on that
motherfucker's face you don't want to
get in there you don't want this going
into the third round i'll tell you that
right it was not going to go to the
third one [ __ ] all over each other
basically
but see football players are never going
to give anybody else credit for being an
athlete
because we're the best athletes in the
world we fought in the nfl and we played
in the nfl and found the ufc i i know so
you're saying you've done neither are
you still are you still carrying one of
your friends you can't have an informed
opinion but compared to matt matrione
who's playing the nfl and that's why i'm
asking but you're not you're arguing
oh good throw son i'm saying that
seems like a hell of an athlete a super
like like for the ufc you see how he
held on to that single that's [ __ ]
that's well taught yeah that's
disappointing and i'm not saying he's
not having that that's really difficult
while it was happening i didn't hear
brian talking about friends you know
what i'm saying or like
when i talk about that
that's like a freak i mean
they're doing a great job i've seen guys
not just him who do nothing nothing
tarzan and james nothing yes nothing is
that right i've seen bigger freaks than
him that equal nothing in the football
and you see people that look like
[ __ ] he's like
you're acting like there's not talent he
seems to be it's a there's a talent
he's acting like he's just because the
guy's big he's [ __ ] tall [ __ ]
i i'm impressed with the fact that first
of all he won a champion he's ufc
champion nothing to do with the nfl
though but it has something to do with
athleticism no it doesn't
has nothing he beats
let's put this to bed right now yeah can
you kind of do this please do matt
if you're going to say that being a ufc
champion has something to do with
athleticism then explain tim tell you
i love i'll do you one bad half off
like how how would nate diaz do in an
nfl comedy that would be horrible one of
the best fighters we've ever had i loved
it and everybody loves nate love him
yeah runs a 7 flat 40 yeah
john jones you would agree is one of the
best to ever do it yes right
he ran a 40. you know he ran who who did
this what john johnson john johnson yep
they asked when we ran the 40. he said
around a 5'3 real quick gsp i was 250
pounds at that time i raced it might
beat them in a race yes i believe that
mm-hmm no one the greatest ever do it i
understand i didn't sniff the unit okay
now would you say that first of all just
using someone's 40 time as a measure for
athleticism is it's everything is best
everything
but not in not in athletics correct so
there you go you just beat your point
what do you mean because those guys
because in athletics the sprint the 40
is everything in the nfl in the ufc it's
not athleticism that wins championships
well it's iq what i'm saying is you're
using it you're saying you're saying
that france mangano probably or gsp of
these guys or jon jones had a slow 40. i
don't think that's the only measure for
athleticism right but in the nfl
especially the scientists they're saying
you're saying i'm not saying they can
play in the nfl i know what you're
saying no you're saying athleticism yeah
i'm saying athleticism and uh sprint is
the most natural thing you can do
forget his knockout power i think he's
done a really good job of becoming a
pretty good wrestler at least stopping
takedowns against sarah gand who's a
non-wrestler but right sierra goes only
take downs he's ever got but he's
submitted a lot of guys with uh
oh
he got him he's got one don't run into
it why is this guy so good yeah he's not
has no grappling wrestling but his
learning seems to know why because he's
heavy-handed his biggest technique
uh
that's what i'm impressed with hey but
hey derek's going to get caught oh [ __ ]
i just say derek's calling that outside
hook oh man two of us i feel like i said
don't rush in i feel like derek has
better i feel like ty has better cardio
oh [ __ ] we got him he got him he got him
he's going back hey for real they can
both come on time
come on they're done they're both tired
if i didn't see it i didn't see the
elbow
his mental issues like he said that like
when he fought for the title he was like
i i didn't want to fight like the
pressure in my hometown was too much hey
i don't fight five rounds what i just
saw was there quit derek got rattled
there got you felt pressure and i saw a
derrick quit now there might have been
devil that came in there and then
dropped him let's see but i didn't see
that
why don't there is a fossa oh dude top
five now oh my god and what's the shoe
he does he's [ __ ] great
i hope i'm wrong i hope i'm wrong i hope
i didn't why is everybody cupped
everybody's kept right now you're gonna
be on the outside he must have done it
they didn't show us huey no he'll do it
right now someone said they they had to
do no i guarantee you steve will do it
is cage side because ufc their partners
with them he's going to toss his show
and shoe and he's going to do a shoe you
can't get in the sludge he just did it
and they they just don't know what they
did they didn't film it no [ __ ] yeah
i don't know
what i said
right he landed
i think i think at this point derek does
not want to see him matt i think he just
got rattled
i feel bad for saying that i didn't see
the elbow yeah that's fair though if you
don't see the replay yeah yeah but no
that was literally you got pretty
rattled before that too man now though
when you look
that's two elbows right that was the one
that derek brunson was the elbow that
finished a fight and this one here you
got two fights back to back to in on
elbows actually it's madness bro hey by
the way uh let me say this to
shout out to tai from not [ __ ] him up
after he was knocked out oh i agree he
knew he was that hey that's classed as
[ __ ] son awesome expect i respect that
well they're the same guy one's in new
zealand one's in [ __ ] houston
i respect they're twins you come get you
come get your number called and you live
and die by by the go first of all ty was
the number 11th ranked heavyweight in
the world number three and knocked him
out of pay-per-view um we're going six
hold on let's see this now um
at any given moment any heavyweight can
change the game yeah they're gonna give
them one punch that's it so eleven and
three doesn't really mean [ __ ] you know
as well as i did the only thing
oh it is all these guys are so big all
it is is for people to talk about that's
all it's fodder that's all
the only reason i disagree is ties never
got over that hump anytime he's fought
veterans he's lost
okay i don't know much about that but
you got you know you have small fingers
do you have my fingers on those big
ponds
huh look at your little fingers dude i
noticed he had bigger fingers earlier
because i'm more observant than you i
don't know man yeah congrats on your
fingers
nobody's ever said that in the world
have you broken every one of those
fingers from football every one of them
uh i broke every single finger except
for my wedding ring finger yeah wow look
at your face is that a is that a rubber
ring it is 100 yeah yeah what else would
you do yeah why would anybody wear
anything i mean i just tatted mine yeah
see you know i wanted to do that [ __ ]
too and i was like you know what man
like can't wait to get that because she
got she got with her first house
well the first option she got queen of
hearts tattooed on her finger and i was
still disappointed and now she's like
what am i gonna do listen i gotta
prepare for the future representatives
always be here yeah i'm sorry
all right
let's just hang out hey dude you know i
don't know that's what i'm saying he's
been roughing chris up all night
man
if i was bigger
because big old sweating
um
i'll tell you what i'll be honest i
think tai of oscar on kratom that's why
i got the knockout when would you
because you uh listen i'm gonna tell you
guys
is my secret weapon
podcasting
it's the limitless pill for your boy
here the best focused product i've ever
used i think ty was using tight i can't
confirm that i think he was again brian
you give him the the website so i don't
mess it up dude it's just happy hippo
herbals.com you said herbals but if
you're from england
there is an h in there and it should be
verbal
if you're creative if you're a marketing
expert you're going to say i want the
alliteration let's call it herbal right
right so happy hip-hop
herbals it should be it should be either
way they love that we keep saying yes
happy hippo happy hippo it's the triple
h it's the professional wrestler
you get you get 20 off when you use the
promo code thick boy on their website
i'm telling you man crazy
stick three three c's i own three c's
anything less than three i don't [ __ ]
with it has to be three c's that's it
thickboy.com i'm sorry okay or no k uh
no case no cases we don't do k it's
t-h-i-c-c
boy for 20 off at happy hippo
h-e-r-b-a-l-s
dot com get the kratom you deserve
speaking of
speaking of brandon branding go to brian
who's that dude right there is that his
homie no that is drink west
chris
that guy drives a uh lamborghini bet my
last dollar on it no you're scared
that's a versace shirt isn't it like
don't touch my face 100 yeah that guy is
one of those roxbury night at the
roxbury guys yes that guy
um by the way i mean we said this the
other day uh rudy hernandez is by far
the best hand wrapper in the entire game
yeah
ball headed dude mexican fella i would
have alright here stitch was great dude
though
i would agree dude which is great they
canceled them i like them both
he's with bellator and boxing what
happened i can't remember he got too big
he was like two he was that two brand
name yeah that's steve will do it right
there hold on they ca they canceled him
because he had he took sponsorships
right oh and there's bradley right there
who tell me that looks like russell that
one guy no i don't know if bradley who's
the comedian has russell the british guy
with long hair oh looks like you come
out uh russell uh brand yeah that looks
like him he's brilliant he's retired
from uh hollywood he's done he does a
podcast and gets i don't know he's six
million downloads no more than four
point five million
he's actually really smart and he's got
a lot to say have you ever heard him go
at it no i mean go at it just like
debate arguments he's brilliant dude
brilliant i'm gonna be totally honest
with you man i have only listened maybe
four podcasts in my life ever like not i
listened to okay listening shop show you
listen to truck and uh
or what are we talking about something
in that neighborhood you listen to music
uh yes a lot yeah what's your what kind
of music um honestly dude i'm i'm a lot
i'm classic rock and medium i'm country
uh i'm i'm hipaa i'm hip hop i'm opera
um
favorite favorite front man of all time
music
that's complicated the guy you want to
be uh axel rose
really yeah of everybody everybody over
freddie mercury over uh i love i love
freddie if i could go over how about
you go back in time yeah if i go back in
time and see five bands yeah right oh
freddie mercury i would say
so my dad saw zeppelin open for a band
back in the day he said it was so great
dj it changed dude uh so uh uh
kurt cobain no right well maybe for you
okay uh
queen uh the doors the cars i would love
to see the [ __ ] car okay okay where's
bts on this list
um then uh i would we just talked about
somebody that brought me to the
conversation and i just got it well we
got zeppelin yeah is it axel rose
actually rose uh and i want to see axel
rose in this prime okay because i saw
axel rose with with uh gnr
three years ago yep and uh cool
yeah wasn't awesome no one i would i
would like call notes
[Music]
you know what i'd like to see the who
and pink floyd oh i would say big boy
[ __ ] so i never saw i never saw the
grateful dead with jerry right oh yeah
because it's not dead with jerry nine
days long yeah john mayer does it now i
i love drugs and i've i'm just joking
though but uh i i've seen john mayer
like probably 15 times with the dead
dead company yes oh wow but i actually
had tickets to go see the dead last show
in chicago 95 but we had two a days we
had camp and i couldn't get out so i had
to give my tickets up and then so i
never got to see jerry and show probably
for the best right you ever had his but
i would see i would say being floyd 100
oh wow i'm not being full fat really
dude i'm deep deep into the punishing
they're astonishing you aren't even deep
in the second game
they're astonished
awesome
i don't know any music but you're
changing everything about it i don't
know how to use it you
is the best album of all time dark side
of the moon okay best album of all time
are you ready for this curveball limp
biscuit prime go
i'm not gonna [ __ ] with nobody i'm not
gonna entertain the connection it's so
silly yeah
uh
did it all for the next but i would
listen to uh says mother down down
oh i love system of it down to it the
toxicity and are said
you're a search-taking guy so do you
know empty wall sergeant jen yeah i know
the guy yeah [ __ ] empty walls that's
one of my most favorites
your voice is so good
it sounds exactly like that no dude it's
astonishing that's the [ __ ] i'm talking
about dude i'm going sleeping i'm going
i want to do it i'm going nickelback got
smack olympus listen man i have a
nickelback t-shirt at my house
are you ready for this though um uh rage
against the machine in the process oh i
saw that
i saw them in there they're doing again
brad wilk the drummer is a friend of
mine so
if you want to go let's get oh i'll hit
up yeah
saw them in there
[Music]
what are you i'm sorry you're next to me
are you a rage guy do you want to go see
your rage bro system of a down and
that's it what about rage you want to
raid
yeah i'll go if you guys go to yeah
when i'm first in la i'm invited to a
running charades party a running
charade's party what is it is this part
of me in fact i swear to god
yeah i get there i'm doing it i'm doing
a sitcom so my buddy invites me he's an
actor oh that's an actor
you know brecken right yeah he's part of
the goldberg show
i get water and i go like this i get
there and it's and it's it's tom
morello's house oh yeah and he's
leading from the charge you're [ __ ]
kidding me dude tomorrow and i'm like
well how am i supposed to act normal and
i'm off well we're just we're all
hanging out and everybody's acting like
it's normal i'm like that's [ __ ] one
of the greatest guitarists
and then we played running he went to
harvard yeah
he went to harvard he's he's like he's
like a total intellectual he's covered
in books everywhere and we played
and all i could think about when we did
running trades is his clue his
list was so unbelievable he and of
course his team won but it was such a
weird thing that's freaking crazy i'll
tell you what's crazy is manscape's
announcing wait a minute their new ultra
premium collection believe it or not if
if listen we know they cover your
private parts they got that lawnmower
4.0 we all use it but you know what it's
above the waist now boys yep it's all in
one skin and hair kit for the everyday
man
we got you covered man we're talking
about premium deodorant hydrating bodies
not body wash right body washes
when i get peppermint eucalyptus it
changes my my scalp well
dude i got you man two in one shampoo
conditioner come on boys let's get after
it get 20 off and free shipping with the
code cfc manscape.com that's 20 off and
free shipping with the code cfc
manscape.com that was perfect that's the
last readout here we go i'm nervous i
gotta pee all right uh
do you hatch who do you got on this
you're a [ __ ] with [ __ ] i think bob
knuckles is gonna be pretty damn good i
think bobby's gonna handle
he's gonna he's gonna is gonna handle
the pressure better i think he's gonna
wrestle a hell of a lot more
you do yeah i do because i think he's
going to look at it
exactly which i think is a mistake and
he gets knocked out because i think at
85 when they go oh yeah you just got to
take izzy down in the middle of cage
because against cage he's too tired cool
you're not 240 pounds john who's a
monster yeah
bobby knuckles and you've been in there
with izzy and also if you think it's
going to be the same as you i think
you're sorely mistaken i think izzy
knocks him out dude because i think he's
been going for the takedown because they
think oh all you gotta do is take izzy
down the middle octagon he can't walk
cage crawling [ __ ] i think he's mean for
a rude awakening um do you feel that
is easy the new john jones
i think he's better
which is a lot to say i think he's more
creative i think he's more dynamic i
think he's a better person i think he's
better you can market him more the
bottom of my shoe is a better person
than john jones he hates jon jones
that's not true i don't hate him i did i
don't like who he is
do you know john i mean yeah
blow your mind what you would talk about
off the show yeah uh i know but what i
will say is that him as a person if i
don't know what i know about him i don't
mind jon jones right i do think he's the
the best we have to offer like if aliens
came like hey who's the best in the
world in the world like jon jones at
heavyweight and light heavyweight yeah i
think he beats all heavyweights
too yep um yeah jon jones is so if he's
motivated he's so capable
and you do it all you know what's
amazing about him dude
is that
that dude beats the best in the world
two weeks on [ __ ] yeah two weeks
training full of cocaine twizzlers like
yeah doesn't give a [ __ ] wins with a
hangover beats the [ __ ] now is that let
me ask you guys this is that why he is
in other words is that that kind of if
he trained really hard and took it
seriously would he be he might become
worse you know what i mean yes you know
what i'm saying yes if you give him
structure like maybe his creativity
comes from the fact that he just so he's
he's he's da vinci right he is a [ __ ]
lunatic yeah right but he's so [ __ ]
crazy that's what makes him special
that's what yeah
if you if you give for example all right
so
my my [ __ ] up brain right if
the antidepressants of the world are
killing art they're killing creativity
they're stifling every bit of of
normalcy of madness
so you know kanye when he's making the
album he gets off antidepressants
because he goes i can't be creative on
it yeah so he gets off that's when he
goes on those weird tangents yeah what
the [ __ ] in order i didn't know that but
i believe he goes in order for me to
make art i have to be off the medication
so when he's like going all crazy he's
making an album you don't want a crazy
kanye yeah but no
i think i think the problem is we want
we want the madness right yeah we don't
mind the madness right but there's so
much attention on the madness now that
we can't handle the madness but like
everybody everything is going to turn
vanilla soon right if we let it
if we let it but that's what cancer
culture will do cancer courses there's
no money
and i hate to quote trump but he says
anything touches turns into [ __ ] he's
right right he's right but in america
but they never thought about the money
aspect of of cancer culture doesn't mean
one thing that woke his touch that's
made profit i can't think of a single
thing no you can't because candace owens
come on in here and she [ __ ] says
most americans most americans i don't
care what color you are are just like
this doesn't make any sense yeah you're
you know what i'm saying but
it resonated hard enough forever for for
whatever percentage to pick up like for
example um
of new york uh wherever else right
having people like we're not going to
give punishments anymore for these these
scenes but how's that going for them
it's horribly but people voted it in
yeah but people said and i just watched
but they lost the hard resonance they
learned the hard way
watch what's the election in november i
get you and that's why they're trying to
get rogan off
a lot of people
was trump's fault because they were it
was like a
reaction trump cricket it's very
polarized it's going to turn full circle
so the position is
oh no you're pushing him chris oh
christmas chris
chris
chris take it chris come back in the
center it's like a gremlin christmas
did you lose time again take it easy all
we're talking about is that is it the
90s now no dude how much time did i lose
no we're just saying wear your mask
that's all we're trying to say because
please when you're going to get your
coffee where your [ __ ] mouth is
behind your ears
because it's the rules
or nourishment there
what's foreign [ __ ] saying speaking
in tongues dude whoa what happened guys
in the 90s no no it's not the night oh
[ __ ]
[ __ ] but to your point i see what you're
saying wait wait till the election
it's not working i don't um
if i should finish that thought but i
will just please do me off yeah um i
feel that if uh if trump runs again
everything goes bad i feel that he can't
run again you can't because he's too
polarizing he's two no you need to
he was villainized too much but is it
desantis or is it
who no i don't know well i think
chris chris is great prince i was too
young at it very smart guy though
i had a long way i had a lot i spent a
whole evening with him talking about
have you really [ __ ] yes why did you
[ __ ] call me we were we were in uh i
think we were because brian's lying
we're in nashville
like
this is called brian tell me he took a
picture and then took it down no the
reason i took it down and i called him i
told him i told
i'm a huge fan of dan crenshaw i think
he's a very smart guy he's i i mean i
really think he's fair because you're
right no i'm he's fair he's very
intelligent when when he voted for that
abortion law in texas which i totally
disagree with can i i i can still be a
good person it doesn't mean you can't
post one person but then i said i said
dan no because hold on what did you say
at the time what did you say it was at
the time that it was news that i totally
disagree with and if you're going to
vote for it which is unconstitutional i
i texted him i said i don't want to be a
[ __ ] i'm not a hollywood guy i respect
you you stay with me if you ever come to
[ __ ] la i love the guy i love the guy
i
and for me at the time i think i was
making a statement because i totally
just but it does seem like you're making
a statement if you do that
i was making a statement i stand behind
it but i like him
but i feel like you can like him and not
agree with his politics
but i would have left them
you could even put a caption like don't
agree with what he's doing with this no
it was already posted so from now you
can you know yeah
you can go in there no i won't don't
agree i won't do it down yeah
really good friends and he just said
something they're gonna pull my pictures
if you're a political figure and you
vote for something that's that
polarizing to me that i totally disagree
with i'm taking but we know he's a good
guy and i i love him i told him that i i
thought he said i texted him i said i
totally get it he goes he goes then
again you know you don't have to agree
with everybody who said that and i go i
understand that too but right now i
don't agree with a lot of these [ __ ]
idiots yeah you know i don't want to be
in i do yeah
how do you feel about congress not being
able to uh invest in stocks if you get
in congress you have to sell every stock
everybody you're related
i totally agree couldn't be the better
who would who would be into that
clearly
there should be no investments at all if
you're in congress whatsoever but
they're doing it
and they should kill it hey so i have a
buddy
this is gonna [ __ ] you up yeah please
have a buddy of mine who um uh grew up
in a very well-to-do family they were
non-political okay and he grew up in uh
a dc area okay and um he went to a
private school a bunch of uh congressmen
lobbyists senators kids stuff like that
very political families that's his
alumni
um went to a spot
and um
and
once he graduated from law school he
opened comment pieces they were like hey
we need
hey we need uh we need it we need a guy
who's not politically affiliated to
access these loopholes that have been
left in laws
so we need to start these shell
companies and access through these shell
companies startups other shell companies
and whatever else and then leave and be
able to take uh advantage of these
loopholes that were left in there and
then if the loophole ever gets exposed
you're on the hook then then you're on
the hook but we'll say we had no idea it
was there oh well swoosh but for
everything that was done
what's he doing watching the money of
some people he always does is your
friend hillary clinton
[ __ ] wild dude yeah that's wild
that's correct you know politics is
there's not a dirtier game he's skinny
he's 6'4 dude i had no idea what this is
is he that tall yeah i had him on food
trucking because at the time um tell me
he had a great personality the best he
was at the laugh factory one he's the
best guy ever was he really yeah is he
really is he's awesome dude
i wanted him to be cool he's great he's
great great you met him too no i've
never met him i just think he's awesome
he's a big fan of the podcast
he's legit five and a half inches tall
over there i'm telling you when he came
on future i go holy [ __ ] dude yeah he is
taller than you brandon holy [ __ ]
and everyone's like dude he could fight
jon jones and he goes i'm telling you
i'm not lying in the ass everybody
thinks i am he gets [ __ ] he's a
little light in the ass for john jones
but he's all due respect very um
he's thin right yeah yeah he's shredded
but
technique-wise he's a [ __ ] nightmare
right right right that gal again she's
always there
she's that chicken so pretty she's so
[ __ ] pretty i don't know who she is
the dark-haired [ __ ] so insanely pretty
hi dude um it's a different girl this
fight's gonna be sick what were you
gonna say though man there's a story
that i know of a chick that was dating
uh a dude
an uh an um mma guy okay and they were
dating they were serious and we know
okay and they were serious dating like
involved okay
and uh
he he goes to a fight and he's just
checked out with another mma guy oh wow
this is sitting in the vip seats wow
um and that guy beat him up
awkward
and like and dude and listen oh no so
the guy who was with his friends hey
that [ __ ] [ __ ] really i believe the knee
kick should be [ __ ] illegal because
that's just some hosting they just did
it so you got to do them right now bobby
knuckles i didn't see it
yeah bobby knuckles he's [ __ ] up
with those knee kicks uh john jones
rampage he did jon jones at a rampage
and rampage said that's one of the
reasons why he didn't knee surgery it
[ __ ] his knee up back wow by the way i
love him is he coming on your show
anytime ever he's been on here
he's and he's on food truck next week is
he really hey casey welcome rampage you
better get a lot you better get a lot of
food man
i am the most fire [ __ ] kicks and i
don't have them i love that [ __ ]
listen i'll just tell you what i got
them to join five supreme camos chris oh
wow yep you're not gonna only got knows
i love rampage
so uh he was entertaining he was the the
coach of the
coach of the triller triad so he was my
coach for that oh because mma vs boxing
uh-huh what is this i'm seeing that
bridge breaks was
um dude i [ __ ] love rampaging i tried
to fight him forever i love him i think
he's a great dude thank god you guys
didn't fight um but dude i love a man
he's such a good dude dude he is uh he's
so casually awesome dude how about so we
always send black cards for the guest to
pick him up yeah and for whatever reason
my team [ __ ] up
and there's no black cars so i sent a
prius that was all dented
and he comes here i don't know if he
said on there he goes dude what the [ __ ]
i go what he goes look go outside and
look at the [ __ ] girl that dropped me
off he was actually a new place man
there's this girl i've been trying to
hit on she [ __ ] sees me getting this
goddamn dented prius he's like you [ __ ]
the whole thing up dude
he's the best i love him dude yeah he's
such a personality and his stories like
about pride you know he talks about
getting paid in cash yeah the suitcases
and the yeah dude your story about uh
big nog is [ __ ] crazy dude about the
safe crazy jesus dude touches my soul
every time every time i think about it
nuts
just too hip man
hey bobby knuckles this one right now
giant spider man look at him
he's trying to get uh
uh
izzy to counter punch bobby knuckles is
the other guy yeah yeah robert is that
his name
his nickname is bobby knuckles the best
game of all time by the way but um
israel's such a nightmare man it's just
along with those [ __ ]
bobby's so explosive though yeah he's
[ __ ] he's got mad power yes he's got
to be somewhat mowery or something he's
got mixed some something in there
oh cool bro
all right dude you know what i didn't
know there's a uh
something's going to happen here oh yeah
chris yeah
chris brian you're good at announcing
yeah i am good at announcing so hold on
here's something
oh oh jesus hey so so uh my buddy yeah
um eddie alvarez yes conor mcgregor yeah
and he said one of the most amazing
things i ever heard in my life
he said it wasn't that conor had mad
power
it was the fact that his his hand went
from set i've heard that to my chin
before i could tighten my neck up jesus
anybody see that that was good in the
middle octagon
he didn't set it up though yeah he just
shot on it i'm telling you you think
he's easy is he's easy to take down that
was a tough sentence you think is easy
and you're not 240 pounds light
heavyweight yawn so all these
middleweights i'm telling you man like
izzy shot for the moon and tried to you
know get to jon jones didn't work out
everyone's like oh there's a [ __ ] in
his armor no you idiots he's trying to
find a 240-pound [ __ ] polish guy
size makes a difference doesn't it guys
yes especially when you don't that guy
with sizes technique don't make yourself
feel any worse oh
whatever he's lighting them up
and this is the best version of bobby
100 this is the this is the best
knuckles i've ever been izzy's lighting
him up like a [ __ ] australian
christmas tree he [ __ ] loves the way
you talk thanks dude matt if a guy like
me picks a fight with you in a bar are
you guys just knocked me out or
something i end up going to jail no i
snap your necklace you squeeze me what
do you do
you oh
i tell my wife to slap you hey wow
amazing amazing
that's super disrespectful that's
exactly right did your wife
because she's so [ __ ] strong and she
does [ __ ] all the time i call it the
pack horse she's like she carries [ __ ]
i'm like how do you care you're going to
have does she run the house she's not
like she's awful she's a [ __ ]
gangster yeah i feel it yeah when she
when she was the food she's like is he
gonna [ __ ] bring it like whoa hell
yeah it is last time i hung out with you
you guys were dating i think you'd have
you just started calling me yeah we got
married in december of 20.
yeah so we got married the last time i
hung out with you was was that turn
around two years before that i thought
was everyone in the match
we were at that bar and across the
street from the club and the healing
very vaguely
you guys have been dating for a while
that was in kilroy's yeah the
breadsticks yeah yeah that you didn't
want to eat because you were not eating
bread
i've parted a lot in my life and i've
never done cocaine no i mean i've known
desire no i don't like uppers yeah i
don't need more energy almost like
another guy no cocaine never never was
interesting like
nicotine i don't under coffee either you
know i know you're a coffee guy yeah
you drink coffee too caffeine kevin are
complete strangers
oh that's a shame
like you're like the dude a nice cup of
coffee the big gulp dude you know what's
so [ __ ] weird to me is my uncle paul
would come to my house with a big gulp
every time i've seen him i'm like god
what a loser yeah and now i have big
gulps yeah but it's of coffee
no this is of a
diet doctor oh i was gonna ask you a
house it's a big dog from 7-11 okay it's
so white iced coffee no it's so white
trash and i love it yeah oh hey are you
hey bobby's getting inside of that jab
gonna get cancer a little bit
i mean knuckle [ __ ] that's how we got
knocked out last night hey by the way i
need to let you know this um that the i
believe the inventor of stevia uh is uh
his son plays football at purdue
um esplinda the inventor of st
he's a rich kid is he any good uh he's
like a third string quarterback uh
quarterback that makes sense i think he
was a walk on because he was a
scholarship quarterback somewhere else
and walked on as a trans girl i'm gonna
have this um but his parents are great
dude great people do you still talk to
drew breese ever yeah actually i i
talked to brees a couple times this year
now he's doing commentating right dude
he works for he's on nfl and i'm a big
fan of him man
who doesn't like drew brees yeah i mean
people are hating on them a little bit
like so strange so i have a story for
you off air about how good that
[ __ ] is like
i
i value him in ways that you'll as soon
as i tell you but like he's such a beast
of a dad what do you have six [ __ ]
kids he's got a thousand kids i think i
think three boys uh maybe four and then
dollars too i thought um
just three boys i think so yeah you
would know i don't um but oh that was a
great uppercut god dang that was so
slick you see how well he timed that yes
uppercut wait he hit him with another
don't get dizzy oh bobby knuckles
no no no no izzy hit it lead up a cut
look at that bobby threw a triple jab
just staying in the pocket dude keeping
the pressure just like he oh he got
caught there this is how robert got
knocked out last night carrot town off
hit me with another cup one time and i
swear to god my whole body went numb and
then i was like i was like don't you
dare let him see that that [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] i was like don't you dare let him
how do you take an uppercut and not fall
down
though i'm not too good at it it's the
job i got here with two uppercuts and
you've got drugs uppercuts seem like the
most devastating
yeah right yes yeah i mean left hook to
the chin dude
no he's not down he's not there oh he is
now no no he's gonna stuck him back he
stuck him back that's not a dick well
now it is
he's got his legs he's got his legs
nope watch this is he against the case
he's got his legs
oh he got it standing up look at that
god dang that was gonna get the
underhood to stand up chris you know
what helps him out is he's so lean and
he's so long if that happens to you like
he's got leverage from positions you
wouldn't expect yeah and that probably
is really strong in there really yes i
do randy couture taught me a position
about on the cage about when somebody's
so tight you can't get an underhook and
you can't get inside of it yeah about
how to handle the pledge of allegiance
put your arm down sink yeah and then
pull them down heavy dude i have never
been able to get an underhook on on
randy ever he's such a freak holy [ __ ]
captain america dude i ever tell you the
first time that i i wrestled with tom
erickson no you know time accidents big
cat yeah big cat dude
i was like hey man i think i'm this is
before i ever started fighting ever this
is crazy huh yeah i'm thinking about
fighting i i i want to go do this blah
blah blah he's like all right come in
let's wrestle a little bit and say i've
never rest a day in my life he's okay
cool man i come in i'm like four minutes
late which is a [ __ ] cardinal send to
him
right yeah so and i like i come in he's
riding the [ __ ] as aerodyn bike and uh
he's humping it and he comes out he's
lathered just pouring sweats
and we i don't know i don't even know
what pummeling is i have no clue he's
like let's pummel yeah he didn't say he
didn't say he just starts pummeling and
that's how i learned the plumbing is
because he was doing it
so like he keeps getting inside inside
body like something like double unders
like back tripping [ __ ] smashing me
just warming up or is he smashing you
there was no one
with coach there's no warm-up you just
go and he was also lesnar's coach yeah
no no that was what's his name uh the
blind hair dude
no not paulson
paul and lyrics didn't work together
though all right paulson and uh brockton
anyways so we're working and then after
like 20 minutes of [ __ ] around i
finally get double unders on them and
i'm like holy [ __ ] i just i just won i
just did something i'm supposed to do
yeah didn't know what i was supposed to
do at all
he [ __ ] lateral drops me so hard in a
way i didn't know what a ladder drop was
right in your face dude he lateral drops
me and lets me go at like [ __ ] 12
o'clock boom six and 12. as we go laugh
fall on all kinds of weird parts of my
body i was like oh what the hell just
happened he looks at me it's the best
way to learn he looks me and goes hey
you're gonna get better and go start
riding the air down back again doesn't
say [ __ ] it's time
hey you need to get better i'm going to
get better and then and i never also a
day in my life and like dude my first
day of wrestling i had ron waterman i
was in his guard
and he grabbed he had those big
packs yeah and he grabbed my face
and he mothered you titty [ __ ] my nose
and made me tap out and i popped up and
i wanted to cry and shane goes come here
he did that to me i go really yeah this
guy
no he's not that guy yeah he choked me
out with his titties oh my god come on
yeah he made me tap too hard
soccer kicked him knocked him out no yep
when i wrestled in high school 1984 he
was on steroids at all oh there's no
steroids there no it's his genetics
looks good to me usado is not stuff he's
got good-looking shorts yeah he tapped
me out with his tits that's unbelievable
hey you know you know
how do you do that
it's called mother's milk
come on dude eric paulson does it no
he's breaking my nose
um oh that's hilarious there's a friend
of mine remember i told you about my fat
friend voice it was so
oh it's so humiliating i was like
everybody imagine the noises
you were making everybody can be made
into a [ __ ]
you can't get your tongue out they say
you know it feels i'll just bite the guy
if somebody's if somebody's crushing you
you can't punch i know your jaw's like
yeah no the worst part was the guys were
all wanted so it looked like i was
crying it looked like i was crying yeah
shane goes you're okay i'm fine
don't talk to me for a little while just
give me that leave me alone
guys don't worry that happened to me i
mean if i want you got good you must
want to [ __ ] kill him never again oh
my only time tapping out with his
titties [ __ ] you
that's a that's so obnoxious
i feel i feel like if you won the first
round the second round was a little
tough probably give it to whitaker the
second round right yeah i don't know
this isn't interesting we've been paying
attention not that much man yeah
you listen to this story no i'm just i
tap out from somebody like doing work
but i say easy for sure
really i'd say it's 1-1 right
that's the third round here is this the
fourth round that tattoo that's the
third round
sounds funny
i think it's one one it's mallory
it's mallory my brother just texted me a
picture of us as children
he's like this is no me oh my brother
is your brother a big kid you're gonna
love this he's not gonna go on the
internet
my brother no 5 10 2 30. he didn't play
football
no not two who's the
kid from uh that's my cousin is your
cousin ty too or no he's mexican he's
adopted he's mexican
and which one are you on top of you in
the past uh that's
the fat kid on the bottom left oh for
sure
look at those fat rules your brother is
bodied up there hey hey look at the way
he's sitting there
big chest
he was athletics too uh bob was that bob
was really good at butterfly there was a
chick remember i told you i was pulling
all the hoes last night yeah there was a
chick last night and i was your wife's
like wait what yo she had this chick had
so much
asymptotized and i was like look we had
a bet at the table we had a table last
night because we're fancy at the
victorian yeah and um and his chick was
was at a group across the way and we're
like dude her asymptotes are so thick
what sport did she play and we had a bet
it was like pretty much split we're
talking about volleyball between catcher
and softball yeah or uh or soccer right
one of them forwards field hockey field
hockey lacrosse volleyballs
what did you do like
she's like well what what do you guys i
think my table has a bet of what sports
you play oh they sent you over yeah well
i went over there because i'm an alpha
okay um
and then she got that astronaut and
she's because the rhythm the back and
the kicks of it like a dolphin oh
butterfly yeah she's like
that's the only sport i ever excelled at
wow with swimming white girls oh [ __ ]
ask for days her ass was straight up
that's genetic that's not from that's
not just a hardcore cake wow that's how
i use it
by trying to but imagine that
i got her number by the way i mean i
told my wife and wife doesn't care
well i mean like she knows i'm not gonna
cheat on her no you're just doing it for
the game you know what i'm saying all
right
yeah everybody should know that matt's
wife is in the next yeah she's right
there so there's this weird page she's
there yeah she's literally right there
oh my god i thought he landed that good
take down bob oh [ __ ] actually not she's
not she left with uh she's out with joe
showing now they're at a bar right now
oh she left oh okay yeah her and joe are
out of the bar she was laughing she left
okay
otherwise i'd be getting texts you're an
[ __ ] right yeah you're gonna get yeah
drink water
man is he did a pretty good job fighting
this off he didn't do that against the
other who is that did that switch on him
too what's and
that can win around
oh yeah this is this is what he means
like this is cage nothing's going on you
take you take somebody no he's being the
enforcer he's he's he's applying the
pressure yeah the knuckles guy yeah
bobby knuckles
for us the lighter guy mm-hmm
robert whitaker
oh
got out of it got back up
okay guys
that's what i do that's why i say that
whitaker's fighting a smart fight man
i wonder if that that take down so you'd
have it
probably two one izzy i don't know i'm
sorry two one uh bobby knuckles
yeah i i don't think whitaker's not
necessarily doing enough to win
yeah but those takedowns count yeah no
but but he didn't do anything though
yeah
it might be right i think izzy won i
think his low kicks looked really good
in the first and then he won the first i
think he's lost the second and third
oh boy ooh that hurt is like his leg's
pretty red too yeah it is
that's not true it depends on the damage
done yeah it depends right
right who inflicts more damage
oh yeah he's good
he's got is his mouth's little buddy
this is so crazy you know um
brendan i know you're training them for
a long time didn't you train with gusen
for a long time
uh when he was at alliance out training
with him that sounds [ __ ] me up that's
what i'm saying um so what what did you
think of he knocked he put me on [ __ ]
fifth street
austin dude i drove down there i was
fighting
i forgot to fight them i've been your
fight he's getting ready for it so i
drive down the spar with him he sparred
eight rounds with a heavyweight
professional boxer beat the [ __ ] out of
him yeah and then i was like oh
does he not know i'm here like no he'll
be ready for you just give him like give
him a minute and then jump in with you
i'm like oh okay i didn't warm but
nothing and i'm going in right hand
right off the bat
get them on
i i don't know how you do before i fight
you oh my god
we got dude my coaches are like okay
well i guess we'll get in the car and
drive back from san diego because this
was a completely different way of time
yeah sweet thanks a lot appreciate that
we were you nervous the whole way going
down there or i mean no the way you guys
at sparrow is [ __ ] nuts dude um
gussison to me
so talented is such an a is it is the
one of the most capable human beings
i've ever seen you know he [ __ ] up
being born when he was born because if
if he was born
five years later he's the best light
heavyweight how does he do right now
right now
i like ben but he's gonna [ __ ] man up i
don't think so he's too quick for man
ben's too tough
ben's durable is fun he's too tough
terrible i think that beats him
because i don't know if he has enough
power to mess up but i think he's going
to touch ben yeah he well he's more
technical i just don't know like that
kick right there that's the one i'm
talking about that i think is [ __ ]
because remember remember but that was
just a tap though well but it doesn't
but
i'm listening to you uh
i was just saying that justifying what
worries about like his mentality he took
all the that time off and retired and
came back so why is he he's a superstar
in sweden like he has billboards he
can't walk down the street in sweden
he's tom cruise in sweden wasn't he
always a little bit on the fence about
fighting no no he wasn't okay but a lot
of people think those those kicks are
[ __ ] though right yeah they still do
them yes but but some guys won't do it
some guys won't guys just don't feel
comfortable doing it i won't i won't i
will not do them hey dude uh i threw a
low kick oh
go uh checked it and i swear to god my
shin was exploding wow like i i like i i
look actually looked down when i started
to put my foot down because i thought it
was just oh no
and i was like oh it's not saying
[ __ ] i was like
like i dude check out go check my cake
hard see i would say robert's up 2-1
would you
yeah i think so just because of the
takedowns yup it's a tough fight to call
oh that's a takedown
notice how he's not letting him get to
the cage wow you know what oh my god oh
i thought he's gonna body triangle oh
boy and then see how izzy walks through
the cage
dude oh oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] dude oh [ __ ] no
come on izzy dude
chris do you have any money on this he's
got him i i've got 11 million dollars
that's too much money i know i do too
much too much
bobby must either not much of a grappler
is he's got hell hips
he's defense yeah because robert had
that [ __ ] pretty locked up that's
crazy
but again though
you were a big grappler for a long time
do you miss her though i grappled the
other day at my son's school yeah and i
was he did i'm good yeah so you go gee
or no gee uh ghee against your son's
friends i know but that's understanding
against your son's friends
i guess yeah because it's not very fair
unless you're going against 19 of them
other dads they're black belts it's nice
that's what i'm talking about right yeah
and that's what i'm talking about too
you hold your arm
yeah do i get my black belt in denver
are you a sneaker head too yeah yeah but
there's a ones yeah yeah is it all come
right back these uh these are jordan's
here yeah i uh
yeah these are
no no no no no these are just honestly i
never wear these i haven't seen those
yeah i know i got them somebody said
what did you say huh what's that shoe
i'll get you something i'll get you he's
a size 15.
because i called
suplex
dude they go
oh we don't have anything really cool in
15 i go send me a picture what you got
they sent those yeezys i'm like those
are perfect that's gotta be the answer i
that's why you wear flip-flops but yeah
explain something to me how do people
that are [ __ ] six eight we're
thirteens and me being six three six
four have fifteens well how does that
work i don't know it just how you know
jesus christ makes people you know and
jesus christ decided to make you with
big feet that's my way you're a good
sister it was jesus
christ
yeah well who makes people then
hey man i i sparred a chick that was six
foot five chick oh my god
she [ __ ] hit me with a question mark
kick
hardest [ __ ] on she's like like hit me
so hard i swear to god it was one of the
only kicks i've ever been kicked by that
was that was days bye because i didn't
expect it
and i started to whoop her ass i was
like you know what i'm gonna fight you i
could do i gotta fight second dude now
and i started throwing low kick heavy as
i could on throwing body shots on her
her name was katya
she was really pretty
really pretty catch your foot right in
my face
yeah please what are you doing now or
something
so we can all see she's back in russia
really yeah just beating up guys or what
um six foot five dude brian yeah don't
just like
say parts of this okay man i'm just
saying dude i'm allowed to [ __ ] fight
i'm allowed to say things yeah that
sounds man what if one of these guys
just [ __ ] in their shorts right i don't
know dude the guy has [ __ ] that'd be
gangster really oh yeah i bet of course
it's only happened once but yeah look at
this this isn't interesting it's
happened once it's happened twice that's
that's what i said we got one last i
think the last round's going to decide
this [ __ ] all right so mike said that
uh annik
john ennik texted joe rogan saying that
uh he thinks izzy hurt his hand
oh [ __ ] really
uh what would you which hand you talking
about i'm not sure not sure when he's
left anymore oh look at him one of the
hands look at him he's not on his right
yeah he's holding it
he's holding it
he's throwing a lot more kicks to him
that hand looks like his right hand
looks limp
um
from my perspective is with his fight so
far damn and dwayne dronson now he's
gonna say this and then take it back
yeah um damn i don't want to see is he
only breathing through his nose midway
through why didn't he even say it no no
i know nothing about fighting don't take
this serious yeah that's cool he said
that yeah
oh girl i said that i'm just kidding oh
oh jokes though no no i know but because
what he did he might have said that no
he should though but he won't right
right yeah
yeah yeah
he likes to tweet during this defense
that's so annoying that he said that
thing after that thing
that's as big as i'm getting dude that's
as specific as i'm getting no you know
but i know what you're saying
i know what you're saying 100 percent
it's so lame and i [ __ ] love the fact
that you say this he's too hot though he
has [ __ ] he has to he's such peace
it's too lame but he didn't have to the
guy just some guy just tweeted it
but
he doesn't want to cut his ticket sales
down but he didn't have to say that he
didn't have to acknowledge anything he
said it beforehand though
then the thing came out and then he's
like whoa
stop responding oh she's there yep i
love her she's i [ __ ] love she's
awesome how she doesn't [ __ ] run and
wins on awesome she lit comedy she
should be she should be she's a she
killed she killed her
she killed her i would vote for her in a
heartbeat the rock
one day and that's the thing i smell
what the rock is cooking is what i'm
saying wow and i smell it
and get political huh no i smell it
because that's what he's going to be
doing i can smell his agenda i don't
like whenever i can see a [ __ ] agenda
dude dude if i can see an agenda i'm out
do i have an agenda you have an agenda
dude what is it dude
is it branding
briancallan.com guys if you if you're
tired of podcasts that go nowhere come
the conspiracy social club the live
podcast
dude it's always trying to sell tickets
man and mine isn't dude if it was i'd be
like i'm going to be in brea i'm going
to be at irvine you go to
christopher.com get any tickets they
listen to my podcast but i don't do that
okay all right dude i'm just saying
brian.com for all those tickets in san
diego or vegas this week
losers uh group up at your shows right
hey what i'm saying
so for your shows yeah right like if you
have a show wherever it is [ __ ] san
diego in the mountains [ __ ]
amusement park exactly exactly that's
not a place you made that up but
if you if you if you are going to do a
show yeah losers group i know i want to
be cool right be cool because i'm going
to get mad i already i'm already a
little on edge so be cool and you know
i'm a friend right yeah and i hate that
i hate that i hate if you think that i'm
gonna be shitty so then really extra
nice but i have good fans
i have good fans i'm a good fan
and i'm very close to him and i have
your back i have good fancy but if i'm
gonna say a group of people that would
convene at one of your shows the thing
that they all have in common is
they're
losers right
they all
that's fake as [ __ ] news and you know it
and you're spreading disinformation and
we have a real problem with this
information right now and you're [ __ ]
lending yourself to that problem
and it's losing
now i apologize to our listeners for
this fake news and this misinformation
if you guys really love to laugh oh no
he got poked in the [ __ ] eye chris
you got all right this is the he says
cool this is the last [ __ ] herb dean
invest in the business
he broke his hand time out he got poked
in the eye dude he might have broken his
hand brendan might have broken his hand
yeah it's a bummer zendaya poked him in
the eye i'm gonna call it
no no come on let's do it put an eye
patch on and let's go
that's how i would fight dude who are
the two thirds
side
you see the two young kids in [ __ ]
that they have dreams they have dreams
to grow up and be fighters
i got my second wind finally yes there
you go chris that's what i'm looking for
sometimes you're a little out of wind
huh
these things are so long
it takes a long time
for sure the sulfates oh
god dude you know what we may have a new
champion yeah
there's no grappling it's just a
takedown and it didn't score that's
control of the octagon and if there's no
do you get points for a takedown after
you take them down that's not a takedown
but it
is controlled
and i want to i want to argue but i
can't he's working okay can you pick him
up here
you say amazing you're doing something
can you lateral drop him like matrion
got lateral dropped all right i [ __ ]
love what you talk
what's he oh he's going for a camera
yeah the reason you dropped he's going
to take down he's got to get up
very interesting
oh he's got water in his ear
is he's gonna scrap is he's in way more
of a scrap than he thought maybe right
i thought there's definitely a tougher
fight i thought izzy would give him out
there in the third though but we said
it's gonna be the best bobby knuckles
ever by far yeah he does look fantastic
dude look at him
i want monster energy just heads off the
center line throwing that jab i just
guess speaking of which i just got a new
[ __ ] tire for real because i [ __ ]
hit a pothole and you're afraid no and
my [ __ ] other your ferrari's still
giving you a problem nope it's all fixed
you just got a new ride how do you how
are you so big in writing a ferrari
burning show i know it's crazy you'll
fit in my friend for sure yeah yeah i
can do another take down bubba
i don't want it
so yeah
if you just get the coupe it's a smaller
cab but i wonder you could fit in mine
yeah yeah
there's only certain fries let me i'm
going to totally ask you a question yeah
the day you buy a ferrari is your dick
grow two inches i think so so i had to
take an ice bath because my [ __ ] is
really big you know it's funny dude like
i wrap it around my leg like a few times
you know yeah and it's annoying because
i have to work because it looks lopsided
so i work my left left leg out extra
hard so it plumps up so i can wrap my
[ __ ] around my right leg oh wow yeah so
i look
interesting how did he get bigger when
to his point did he get bigger when he
bought that ferrari um i didn't know was
it was it
was a buying ferrari
decision
i love you like this is my goal i want
and you hit this number and you're like
yep and i had to get allocated the frog
was the fright club was it you hit
the 13 year old talking about those two
kids
the way he just stopped what he was
saying and it was huh was so good that
was unbelievable well you said ferrari
club and he goes because the way you
hung a couple of new zealanders that was
a good fight like let's say good fight
seriously you can't go buy a ferrari you
have to be everything one bro you have
to be in the club uh i think they're
going to give it to winter i tried to
get rid
zendaya says he won i'm happy with
either but yeah izzy was going like this
to him like do they love that kind of
[ __ ] do they
it's tough like if i'm here i'm working
right yeah like previous cars you've
owned stuff like that
celebrity
right they'll get you more to the side
just get one that's a few years old it
doesn't matter you could do that
if you want to use money what do you
guys think man you think i think i think
bobby knuckles won the fight and i think
those 13 year olds don't know what
they're watching i
although
there's a lot let's see uh
oh i think i have to agree i think bible
never don't say although and then
nothing what sentences
even though he didn't complete a full
takedown it's still an aggression of it
i think he did he did better on jabs too
a takedown is a takedown and then in
control he had control yeah
but i think it's a movement of dominance
hey that was well-timed like this
that's a takedown got it
his butt hit the ground right oh
god those guys are
and they're gonna fight us no they're
taking too much damage and bobby bobby
pressed bobby pressed the issue i think
bobby knuckles won i think they fight a
third time
and i think you won for look at this
dude this is clear as day one i mean i
don't know this isn't like a time it
makes for a good trilogy here i get i
guarantee if uh izzy's hands broke the
third fight he's gonna beat him so yeah
the beautiful part of it is if it's a
third fight that's gonna be awesome and
but you don't you don't do anything else
you have to give him a third fight yeah
izzy's been a champ for but of course
so if he wins then that's the beautiful
part they both look like they just went
to the [ __ ] supermarket right now
[Music]
they went for a little jogger okay so
hang on there's four of us what's the
five o's what's up what's up man i said
uh
so four to one bobby
oh wow no [ __ ] way am i right i mean
i'm happy for him yeah
i think just because uh
very confused is it because he's the
star
because you ain't do you have the
outperformance in order to be the champ
that doesn't make sense i know they say
that you gotta beat the champ to uh get
the belt oh yeah unanimous not even
split so you know that's very good
he didn't win that's not rounds very
it's not right very confusing
they gotta fight a third time like you
wanna see him versus cannonaire
that's weird you wanna see him versus
the guy that fought early and beat uh
wesley snipes from demolition man wait a
minute if this is that what's going to
happen yeah
this is almost a reverse of what
happened with jon jones and gustafson
right because jon jon jones gussen won
was [ __ ] incredible like this fight
could have gone either way
and then um john jones gustin two john
whipped his ass quick kale what does
that head kick it's like he did like
like like izzy did the first one yep so
this is
it's confused what's he saying what's he
saying can you hear do you have autism
uh mike does
hey mike what's he saying
is the idea
uh
is the idea that you have to take the
title away from the champion no that
doesn't make sense you know what i mean
though is that what they're saying
though it's a fight you know what i mean
though
have you been located before
i was like how low could give you
dude you did that to me i care enough
about that matt you did that [ __ ] to me
and i my [ __ ] leg and you touched me
and it hurt that's that's conjecture
that's not true oh my god
you were showing me how you do it you
keep your leg really loose and i was
like oh my i don't know if it fits but i
just felt like i wanted to say a
powerful word but yeah it would be very
cool if you fought the whole time with
that coming guys we did it again huh
like ben henderson fights with a
toothpick yep
no it's the most annoying thing in the
world that's so dumb but he keeps it he
gets it right here oh good you'll
swallow it one day yeah
all good you'll be bleeding i think
he'll be bleeding he's retiring any day
now he's never swallowed it no dude oh
he he just won
he's he's re-upping his contract he said
ben said i feel like i've underperformed
my bellator contract and i want to give
them their value wow that's cool wow so
i don't know if he's going to take less
money or whatever that means but they
just whitaker has to think you won that
fight i wonder what they do with him
because he's 2-0 now
i would like where's he from this guy
australia australia
and he's a full-on and izzy beat him to
lose his title
izzy got his title from bob and then he
won three in a row that's really
confusing to me man no it really is i i
mean i don't get it oh yeah he kept
taking him down yeah we kept talking
[ __ ] and we didn't really watch the
fight entirely so we don't i watched it
man just from the parts
yeah but
this would have been even more exciting
if he had won and now is he's going to
do a trilogy
he's a little bit of a boring fight i'll
be honest with you i mean was it i think
so that's pretty good i think maybe our
conversation was fantastic so it seemed
like maybe it might be our conversation
might have been an artist yeah
that is cool right well because that's
called a cliffhanger so you've got to
and you've promoted your dates 19 times
come on no i didn't hey that was a big
place in san diego yeah 60 seats right
it's crazy there's sometimes bigger uh
see more seats on a bus hey
hey dude hey don't drink they're bigger
seats yeah the entire southwest no but
i'm just saying sometimes
like the venue you're playing right yeah
might as well be a van no
no it's like a
uh rv no
it's cool because
two families can come see you okay man
all right
like uh they have uh
that's crazy dodgers fan have you ever
been to a baseball game you ever watched
a baseball game yeah my son's first game
was a dodger game you never watched the
game gotcha
[Music]
dude
yeah uh yeah i love the dodgers man um
name one player
sean green
you keep skinning yeah name one more
kurt gibson
you're drinking a lot of water you guys
swallowed you gotta stop drinking the
water man come on
ah [ __ ] he's pissing everywhere
burning shop you
um
kevin and i talked about it before
you go back in time what are the
what are the three to five bands you see
that are no longer active bands they're
not your primers
that's it and then i go home i see tupac
and that's it
in the show we're in the studio it's not
a bad call i see two park no matter what
i don't care what he's doing he'll be
shopping i'll watch two parker before i
watch anybody
i love too much on my list for sure for
real hell yeah yeah kurt cobain yeah um
yeah we know who's in it so um and then
also the drummer for the foo fighters
when when jewel was james
when they dropped never mind when they
when they dropped it
jewel said that there was just one album
yeah that one album everybody in a hair
band went oh my god and she knew this
she i didn't she said knew this guy in a
hairband and he was at the airport and
he heard
teen spirit
and he went he they're on their way to
japan and he goes i'm not going like
what do you mean he goes it's over for
us do we tell that story yeah so that
story is a crock of [ __ ]
tell me something tell me this guy was
like
no no no no no that art for me they they
came along with that they're with his
voice
because nobody else was doing that and
it came along at a time when it was all
tricks and hooks and they this guy comes
along and you can just hear the angst
and he's telling stories and it was just
honest so are you saying you went holy
[ __ ] but
when i stepped on the scene comedy brian
lost a lot of fans like they just go
they go oh this is the guy no no no no
this is how you're
and and then and then you listen to me
oh dude that's not it man you listen to
me and then and i and you look at me
when you look at me you think ascension
right
you do you think essentially no i don't
you never use that word you're using
huge words dude you're using huge words
that's the most capable you use this
sentence
oh man hey
somebody's been reading dude
congratulations that's my podcast yes
and it's funny because i know you've
seen every episode you're caught up
right yeah yeah of course
yeah i love your podcast it's
astonishing thank you you know what your
podcast is and i never use this word yes
ever i've never seen and i never use
this word
[ __ ]
and i and i'm embarrassed to say it oh
okay what but and i'm gonna open myself
because i feel vulnerable saying oh
you're a podcast congratulations [ __ ]
breathtaking
two words i know i could be hyphenated
[ __ ] that's amazing i know i get
emotional really it's so good i learned
wow like everything is tough and then i
listen to that and it's like everything
goes away wow i like your podcast more
than my own
kids
i know i'm astonished i said that
i know man my god dude is that it that's
it all right fellas i'm in sacramento
february 24th through 26th and then
early march i'm in nashville and i close
march with chicago
uh that's it man tickets at thickboy.com
mavic your own we [ __ ] love you dude
gentlemen crushed it's been an honor and
a privilege thank you very much now
you're going to get wild yeah i can't
believe you're going out after this
punch where are you going
you don't want to know about that all
right you don't want your friends no old
guys he was texting me where he was
going earlier and trust me you don't
want to know listen brian does uber now
so i try to have a good time that's
right you want me to drive it right now
drive yourself i got to test the three
it's not going to reply i'm ready to go
um yeah i took a minivan home last night
did you i felt good in it wow follow him
christian and brea next week
and then irvine chrisley.com you know
how you know yeah king of this christian
you want me to american comedy club yeah
no open for you or do you want to
moderate the debate
hey
sorry
no you want
yeah you want
come on all right i can open for you
sure but after i go the show's over
after i go so is the crowd
hey
b you're me in vegas i'll be in vegas uh
this saturday this thursday san diego
american comedy club company saturday
and then i'm appleton wisconsin
beginning of march
where where in wisconsin appleton
appleton is a [ __ ] great time i've
heard great little city it's a little a
little shy of uh green bay so but it's a
college town oh it's good it goes hard
it's cool there it goes and i got i got
stand up live phoenix arizona uh march
11th to the 13th and in louisville
kentucky have you done louisville comedy
club no all right i'm there march 17 and
19th did you in port charlotte florida
that's a made-up place yeah so it was
vissonix nice that's a great theater i
love it
just had a sale on letters and put them
on your website huh
you just they had a sale on letters and
you just put give me a v and an n and an
s
that's a real place
actually it's great food we're having
south florida
you know
hey everybody go see brian he didn't
even know where he [ __ ] is dude hey
why
but let me tell you something nation
combines uh comedy clubs and strip clubs
that's a bad idea
they used to distract you no they used
to lenny bruce used to open used to do
performance strip clubs that's where you
did comedy
but i'm old enough when a lot of my
friends did comedy including rogan at
strip clubs
that's how we started really yes i did
my set for comedy central that's not
happening at the strip club we should do
this
uh which one i would say
telling us that he used to be i think
bill burr probably did i i think rogan
did ever um
so tell me something
how do uh
how do comedians
hit it because most of the time it's the
same like like there could be a
community that's been doing it for 17
years and all of a sudden
like like right like lewis how do they
hit it twenty special
you earned it over time but then all of
a sudden it just clicks why what is more
people say did you find the recipe
youtube podcasting really helps now it
it more people see you it's about
eyeballs really yeah is that what it is
yeah like burr had this thing that went
viral it was that thing that he was
talking [ __ ] about philly in philly yeah
and it just went because he was doing a
rough philly
everyone was bombing and he went out
there and he was like [ __ ] you
[ __ ] i'm not going to entertain
you
but it's also like sebastian he had that
showtime special yeah it's always
wonderful sebastian uh sebastian
alexander mattis
galco melissa
you say the first
name yeah
like for family households like italian
he was like he was a major name for a
half-time show or some [ __ ] like that he
was a big something they did yeah he
hosted the show oh yes via that's what
it was
that dude is a family comedian he's also
older and it's millennials it was just a
bad it doesn't make sense his agency
should have said we're not doing this
yeah this makes no sense but it was such
a big opportunity they're like [ __ ] it
yeah yeah but but it hurt him more than
help well not anymore his outfit was lit
as [ __ ] yeah no that guy is he's the
best truly funny yeah really if that's
what you got to give another chance oh
yeah yeah oh no he's not but it's just
his act like i hear him and i'm like i
just don't want to hear anything yeah i
might not be here like that for me yeah
i think some guys are [ __ ] really
good but they just don't make me laugh
you know and like they're not for me you
know
you know likes
ryan
no i'm just saying like
anybody you might think but yeah not
anybody why you keep looking over here
man
why do you keep looking over here no i
like you i think you're right
what we what about a cup you keep
looking over people say should i go see
brian cal and i say yeah he's a good
person no that's not what i want you to
say you keep looking over here and your
eyes go dead oh no all right well look
at me with with with eyes that are
living
your eyes keep going dead dude i think
you're a good uh you're a good guy
you're a good comic you're good when
you're on stage you're a good guy
oh man this is not a good endorsement
all right let's hit that deli meat man
yeah bro i hate it all right love you
guys we're out you ate at all
you